What a weasly little liar, dude. What a weasly little liar, dude.
I'm sorry. Like, dude, that is entirely standalone. He's trying
to load context in there that doesn't exist that he explicitly
filters off himself. He just lied blatantly there. Dead to rights.
>> I don't even know what the joke is supposed to be here.
I don't even know what the joke is supposed to be. >> Kger,
don't don't time Riyle out for a week for telling you to kill
yourself. Okay. In a video game, he disavows. Stop giving them
all the ammunition in the world. Stop rage baiting about yourself
being a
what? How does he say that with his straight face? My edgy clips.
My edgy way older than Ethan's. Brother, I'm pretty sure you're
talking about [__] 15-year-old last week. >> My
name is Victoria and I'm 15 years old and I don't care what my
mama says. I'm going to have a baby. I will do whatever it takes
to take care of my baby. If it has 10 proxit in my body, then
so be it.
Please culpable for the on his computer received. Let's go. We're
here. We're finally here. >> Hold on. I >> We're
rolling up to the reaction. >> A whole meme and everything.
>> Okay. Keep me on track. >> Let's go.
>> We need to preempt this or can we just >> Okay.
First purpose. I have been relentlessly attacked. Okay. By the
clients. All right. Um, Ethan recycles a whole bunch of stuff
from a Ryan Beer video plus other things. There's a whole bunch
of like random statements that people make about me and about
things that I've done, you know, 12, 13, 14, 15 years ago. And
I figure I could probably just address some of these while going
through the Ethan video cuz why the not people wanted me to watch
the um for my fans. And believe it or not, somehow I guess I'm
sorry uh for Ethan and Elo, but apparently I do have a decent
number of crossover fans from H3H3 and uh from my universe. So
uh this is for them as well, I guess, cuz I I it's kind of nice.
I guess a lot of H3 fans have reached out to me and like apologized,
which I think is kind of cute. Um, but I'm sure there are just
as many also calling you, which is also cute. So, yeah. Uh, >> I
am so sorry that people are holding you responsible for collecting
I am so I sir sir, I am very sorry that people are trying to
hold you responsible for collecting child abuse materials. Okay,
that is not your fault. And really, it's just like all snark.
It's just snark. Okay, I'm so sorry that you're a victim of snarking
right now. There's so many snarkers.
There's so many stalkers.
>> I'm not really I don't think at this point just because
of how hard Ethan has kind of gone in on this, I don't really
expect to change his mind. I don't really expect to change the
audience's mind. Um Ethan kind of has a history of deciding to
like go nuclear on certain content creators cuz he's convinced
of some weird thing. Um he brought on that one girl and for Noah
Samson's stream to reveal
what what was it ultimately that like he cheated on her while
they were dating. So, it was kind of like assault because um
she could have gotten an STD. It was some stupid thing. He did
it with Aban Preach where he's like, "These guys are secret red
pill content creators." He brought on the one girl um relating
to the fresh trying to accuse Myron of like assault when um >> even
the girl didn't want to go that far and Ethan was >> hardcore
poisoning the well on Ethan Klein. Let's go. >> Would you
say he assaulted you? She's like, "No." Um so I I don't really
expect him to ever to ever change his position on this. >> Yeah.
I I it's so good that Destiny put those five hours in last night
to learn about all of those things, right? He was 100% on board
with Ethan Klein until Ethan Klein criticized him and then last
night e Destiny just discovered that Ethan Klein did this to
ABBA and Preach and then he did it to Myron Gaines and he did
it to Noah Samson. And I'm so glad that Destiny did the research
to figure that out last night and totally flip on Ethan Klein
and say Ethan Klein's a total piece of [__] right?
as opposed to like, "Oh, Hassan Hassan's like actually saying
Ebo's a valid military target." Uh, guys, the clients are getting
harassed like crazy. >> Or for the HBH audience in general,
but like I said, I figure I can address my audience and I can
address any crossover fans cuz why the not. Um, there are a million
things that are happening right now in the world. Uh, obviously
relating to the Trump stuff, relating to insane stuff. Oh, guys,
isn't it? I believe that's focus on politics. Okay, I think that's
focused on politics, guys. I would just rather, you know, rather
than talking about my my collection of child, I would much rather
be dealing with the rising threat of fascism in my country. Guys,
there's a rising threat of fascism and I want to be focused on
politics and these people won't let me. They won't let me focus
on politics. Let's ignore the fact that the only reason this
became a thing is because I sent PII explicitly in DGG chat for
Rose allowing Kiwi farms to dock her. That's the only thing that
made this relevant. Let's ignore that though. Okay, we need to
ignore that. That'd be weird to focus on that. Um, just in politics
in general, uh, I've said this a lot to my community. I'll say
it again. I kind of wanted to not be in the whole drama fest
slinging uh, field of whatever the [__] this kind
of drama [__] is, but I guess I'm destined to be
pulled back in. Okay. Okay, I guess I think we can all we can
all see how totally fake this is, right? How obviously fake it
is. He's so above the drama, guys. Pay no attention to the fact
that I explicitly named Kiwi Farms while dumping multiple pieces
of information that would lead you directly to this minor I okay
in May at the very end of May, basically 3 months ago, right?
But guys, 2025, that's the year of no drama. I cut all the toxic
people. I cut all the toxic people. My life remains toxic. It's
almost like there's something I can't see that is toxic in my
life. What could it be? What could it be? It's like when John
Wick's dog is killed, you're always coming back to this world.
So, here I am. Um, I will say as a reminder, the only reason
why this back and forth is happening right now is because Hassan
and all of the other crazy obsessive communities around him like
desperately >> uh the is that a cabal reference? Hassan
and all the crazy, desperate communities around him. I'm gonna
call that a Cabal reference. Okay, the Cabal is already referenced.
There's a conspiracy of people who are making this into a big
deal, guys. And the it's all it's all a joke. It's all I don't
want to be dealing with this at all. I'd rather be dealing with
Trump and Charlie Kirk and un America.
They want to make anything that they can about any random personal
smears as opposed to actually talking substantively about literally
any issue ever. But hey, you know what? If that's what we want
to do, then it why not? Um, not to say that people should be
able to freely rape people or murder people or whatever else.
I mean, obviously that's not good, but that makes no sense, but
he likes to do this, right? He likes to engage in drama fully.
Let's not forget that he's been doxing people for the past couple
months, right? He's been openly doxing people, taking full responsibility
for trying to dox people, right? He's been doing this. And then
he goes, "Guys, I don't want to do, by the way, not political
content creators." Just to be clear, he's not doxing political
content creators, right? I don't I don't understand. You would
have to be brain damaged to take this double standard seriously.
To take these words seriously, guys, I don't want to engage in
drama, but like I'd rather focus on politics, but you know, they
keep pulling me back in. They just keep pulling me back in. I
don't know if me and Ethan are now going to be locked in a twomonth
snark fest where both of us just play each other's greatest hits
on repeat over and over again. If that's what Ethan wants to
do, though, I mean, I've had people do this to me for years,
so I we can [__] do it for more, I guess, if we want.
Um, I will say that the inciting incident, uh, because nobody
actually seems to give a, which is fine. I understand. I'm a
guy, so revenge.
Ooh, the inciting incident. What is the inciting incident?
It's going to be
He said revenge. Oh, it's going to be the inciting incident was
when people leaked revenge me to Kiwi Farms. That's what incited
all of this was just it's all just my revenge Kiwi Farms. These
people are using my revenge to attack me. Um, wait, does your
re revenge involve like you having a sex relationship with a
minor? Having a a online sex relationship with a minor? Yeah,
but but the inciting incident was the the leaks and all that
is epic and hilarious. But the only reason a lot of this stuff
is even in the public conscious is because of a guy who in 2024
decided to dump like 25 plus explicit videos of me on the internet.
Um, a few of these contained other people. The majority of these
I think like 20 of them were literally just pictures of me stroking
it. Uh, so thank you for that. I'm glad that Where's all the
people making fun of you stroking it? It seems like the criticism
that's persisted
to me seems pretty obviously on the non-consent elements here.
the non-consensual elements where the people also involved were
in those videos or the minor child who you're sending those videos
to. Where's the criticism? Is anybody making fun of you for sucking
dick right now? Is anybody making fun of your technique for sucking
dick or some [__] Like, yeah, those were those those
were jokes. Were those jokes we couldn't have made? Okay, hold
on. Anemone, were those jokes we couldn't have made from previous
leaks that he didn't care about? That he openly said he didn't
care about that he posted on Kiwi Farms despite them being posted
there? In any case, the the idea that this is mostly about his
revenge is preposterous. It's about his lack of respect for women's
consent and the fact that he was carrying on a a relationship
with a minor. That uh the entire internet can enjoy that. I love
to share myself with
all of my wonderful fans and auntie fans. Thank you so much.
I would say that in general, the reason why I'm usually reluctant
to address stuff like this when the Ryan Beard video came out
is I don't like the concept of relitigating every single bad
thing that's ever happened in my life, which is basically what
happens is anytime somebody runs out of content or they want
to fight with me or I say something politically that picked them
off or I, you know, basically just point out like, oh, I think
this opinion is done or whatever, people break the in case destiny
destroys you in a debate, break glass here and then pulls out,
what about 14 years ago? What about in 2012? what about in 2013?
I was like, okay. So, again, I would expect him to just lie about
the the pretense for this. The thing that changed, everything
here was sort of like dead, stuck, no movement, right? The thing
that changed was Destiny himself taunting Kiwi Farms, posting
PII and new pictures that only he had of this Rose person, this
minor that he was with, right? He posted these pieces of information
and taunted Kiwi Farms to find them. That is the thing that changed.
He perpetuated the cycle. He is the person doing this to himself.
But he is going to say, "Well, it's because they lost a political
debate with me." No, you were explicitly
referring to Kiwi Farms. You were explicitly mocking them for
not being useful or not being good at investigating things and
then you gave multiple new pieces of information to them. I don't
know what the you want me to say about this or how many times
I need to say something about this. Um, I do think it's a little
bit funny because I think Ethan actually like intuitively understands
this. I actually think he explained it really well when he was
talking about how Keemstar operated in this video. >> Just
to give you an idea of how Keemstar torments and harasses people
on his enemy list, let me show you some of the DMs he sent me
over the years. Now, these are cold DMs. I've already unfollowed
him.
>> I can somebody explain to me how So, this is this is
basically
[__] I feel like I might 2x through the Ethan clips
that are apppropo of nothing. I don't care about Ethan Klein's
hypocrisy here. I care about Desessie's response to the idea
that he has been holding that he hasn't informed the proper authorities
that he alleges that his lawyers told him to keep that. Right.
And any responses that have to do with how old Rose was or how
old he thought she was. That's this will just be what aboutism.
But isn't Ethan Klein a hypocrite? Can Ethan Klein really ask
ask me these questions when he's a hypocrite? Right. This is
the precise deflection he is criticizing Ethan for is what he
is about to engage in. This slight of hand is very obvious to
anybody who's watched him for any period of time. Uh it's obvious
to me. It should be obvious to you, right? He is performing the
exact slight of hand that he is accusing Ethan of. And he is
sending me these DMs unsolicited out of the cold blue for the
express uh purpose of harassing me. So I really don't feel bad
sharing these tweets at all. Currently working on a H3H3 lying
salty manchild video. Have a few questions. Have you ever flagged
down another YouTuber creator's video? I don't answer. And he
uh persists. Can I get you to defend yourself? In fact, if you
like it there,
I'm putting massive air quotes about this right side. >> Okay.
Hopefully hopefully we can get through. I don't I do not care.
>> Oh, I just wanted to address this before we get into
things too. Again, I don't know how many >> Looks like
looks like Keemstar's cold, but I get a little bit triggered
especially when all the I'm putting massive air quotes about
this victims or whatever come forward and Ethan Klein subreddit.
I think the one I read the second part was the girl was like
I was 16 talking to some guy online and he said he was 16 and
I felt abused and afterwards I don't even believe he was 16.
I don't even know why though but I yeah and it's like what the
am I even reading right now? sounds like all of the all of the
random posts about this like what >> what is this relevant
deleted by Reddit so I don't have a copy of it right now but
I'm like okay there's something I spoke about before uh it's
kind of cringe but when people talk about predatory behavior
um I think that people talk about stuff that I would consider
like yellow flags but people would pretend that predatory behavior
isn't just yellow flags or even red flags um or rather they'll
point to like a thing that's like a yellow flag and they'll say
that that's like abuse so somebody will say something like oh
there's um you know there's a difference in status cuz this person
is like a fan or a content creator, this person is, you know,
older than that person or this person is more money or stronger,
whatever. There's always power imbalances in relationships to
some extent unless you're literally dating your twin um who had
the same amount of training and job success everything else you
for your entire life. Uh I think okay I
is he going to like where's the we played a significant portion
of Ethan's video yet or what what are we responding to here?
We're just making a point about like, oh, I'm I'm probably going
to be called a predator here, so I'm going to make some points
about yellow flags. I >> I think that it's fine to point
out like yellow flags or red flags when it comes to certain behavior.
Uh, I don't think there's anything wrong with that, but to automatically
just assume that somebody is like manipulative or evil or predatory,
especially when there's absolutely zero evidence of that ever
being presented ever in any public place ever, despite everybody
saying it over and over again. Are we just going to like openly
lie? the idea of you being like malicious or predatory. There
absolutely is a pattern which is why you won't look at the Ryan
Beard video in full, right? Why you refuse to respond to the
Ryan Beard video in full.
Uh it's why you you try to present it reviewing Ethan's video
as responding to the Ryan Beard video. So you're a disingenuous
loser, but like this would be this is best encompassed by the
Anavar situation. Right? Now, that's not accusing him of child
predation, which I don't think is like realistically I don't
believe accusing Destiny of being a persistent child predator
is like a very valid claim, right? I don't think I don't think
he has primary attraction to like prepubescent or even pubescent
like teenage kids. I don't think that's the case. I think trying
to present it that way, you're just going to trip over yourself,
right? I it seems more like he has gotten to the point where
he
he just doesn't care and and he he excuses a lot of the you know
the transgressions the social transgressions and as he
he can identify exactly why he should stay away from that line
of 18 right why he should never stretch beyond that line I'm
not interested in trying to say he's like a persistent child
predator I'm saying he has he has maintained a trove of or appears
to right
and and then he's persistently I would say, would you say predating?
I don't know if predating is the right word. You know, you want
to be careful with your accusations. Again, like we were talking
about earlier, Destiny uses like any attack service you can give
him. He certainly is willing to uh like abuse his platform to
get interactions with women, right? This abuse as in use his
platform to gain leverage to to have leverage to sleep with women.
That is like absolutely something he does, right?
Like and he forms these relationships purely asymmetrically.
Like these people are fans most of the time. They DM him. These
are like actual allegations. I I think a lot of the stuff that
Ethan gets into
um Predator is a little bit different. I would say this isn't
predating on um it's like you set up a filter that that ends
up with this happening. It it's a very complicated thing to explain.
Uh I would have to lay it out. I have to write it out to do it
already. But
um we'll get into it. I just don't think that trying to call
him like a persistent child predator is effective.
And I think that's what Ethan's core premise was. It wasn't Ryan
Beard's core premise. I don't think it's anybody's core premise
that is intelligent in analyzing this situation. I just feel
like it's really cringe. Um I've heard Ethan and other people
argue uh that like streamers shouldn't uh you know engage with
fans in any manner or whatever. If you want to have that opinion,
I guess you can. I think it's kind of a funny one because I personally
I would argue that there's way more like power dynamics at play
between creators versus just creator fans because for a creator
fan basically the worst thing that can happen is you the person
stops watching you I guess and maybe you lose a subscriber but
um creator creator stuff can be a lot more strange because now
both of your jobs are potentially on the line one person has
a lot more to gain than the other person. There's like people
have seen >> describing his longest persistent relationship
with his ex-wife Molina. Um, interesting gambit, I suppose, but
kind of kind of seems odd to me. Not Not She She literally came
to America, didn't have a lot of money, didn't speak the language,
and became a Twitch creator. I I thought his insistence.
That's a little weird. The The real predation happens in like
my longest relationship with my ex-wife. That's where the real
predation happens. >> Creators split before those situations
themselves to like insanely problematic dynamics. Uh, not to
say that those shouldn't happen either. I'm just saying that
it's always good to
like keep in mind that there are red flags
mean something is like predatory or abusive or manipulative or
evil or
um whatever else the um
Okay. Okay. All right. I've segmented this off into segments.
We'll just I'm playing most of this video straight down. Welcome
back guys to another video on demand. Today I'm going to be addressing
once again the allegations leveled against Destiny. Since we
put out our last video, there's been a lot of chatter about the
things that we may have got wrong. So, I'd like to clarify what
I got wrong and also to clarify what I got right. So, let's I
do want to start though by setting the expectations and just
kind of giving some context to who this guy Destiny is. I think
just as a quick thing, I like that before he gets into the meat
of, you know, all of his criminal accusations, we're going to
spend like >> Please, please do not accuse him of of poisoning
the well after you've spent like a good 10 minutes here just
talking about all of his including bringing up a video. Please
please don't please don't do that. That would be insane, wouldn't
it? Like 15 minutes poisoning the well. But okay,
Come on, brother. What do we
>> What are we doing here? >> A lot of people haven't
seen this. And when you just I feel this context is important
when understanding this story. >> Also, major props to
Ethan. I can tell that he inhaled the up before doing this video,
so I wouldn't make fun of his cough. I'm glad I can encourage
you to adopt healthier habits. Now, do we count that for mocking
Ethan's tick? Is that mocking Ethan's tick? I think we could
we can scratch that off for mocking Ethan's tick, right? I think
so.
Yeah. Yeah, I think so. >> If you'll indulge me here, I'm
going to pull up some clips from this Ryan Beard uh video on
him that was recently made. And I think these clips are more
relevant now than ever before. So, let's take a look at them.
Section here of harming women. I'm going to show you guys a few.
Around the end of 2011, Destiny assaulted a woman on his live
stream. I'm not using the word allegedly here because we have
video of him doing it and he has openly admitted that it was
assault. I would say that in my streaming career in the past,
like totally publicly, like I completely and totally like assaulted
a girl on stream before for like 5 minutes or whatever, I got
super drunk and was like grabbing her breast the entire time.
Later, Destiny has attempted to downplay his actions here by
tweeting, "I was drunk off my ass, literally for the first time
in my life." And he said that at the time he didn't understand
how bad it was, but now looking back years later, he understands
that it was reprehensible
>> It's like that one guy Mango who got like totally cancelled
for did, but way worse. Mango wasn't actually groping people.
And also there I like this >> like Mang First of all, how
old was Mango again? Wasn't this like a known problem? But okay,
>> this um
there's this >> Wait, how old is Mango? That's a good question.
Wait, how old is Mango? Mango age smash.
Mango is 33. So about 10 years older than Destiny was, I think.
>> Vod on demand. Today I'm going to be addressing once
again the allegations leveled against Destiny. Since we put >> I
just clicked on the wrong video. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops.
We're back. As long as you're radically honest about what you
did, it's okay. It's like it's called based.
>> Did you just say you were groping a woman on stream
for 5 minutes?
But anyway, that's not honestly.
Okay, for the first one, okay, cuz I know that Ryan likes this
clip and a bunch of people like bring this up. One, this in
um I I think from our previous watch of Ethan, the criticisms
we had here were I had was like like as long as he apologized
for this and made amends for it and kind of moved on, I'm okay
with that. Like you're honest about it, you apologized for it,
you didn't make excuses
for it at one point, then I'm okay with this. So, we'll see what
Desi's response is. I'm guessing it'll be like we we cleared
this up. It's all fine. Why? Why are you have such a problem?
Occurred in 2011. Okay, this was 14 years ago when I was 22 years
old. All right. I don't understand how you think could say that
I'm downplaying my actions when in the video I literally explicitly
say I feel like this was sexual assault. Uh I said that my feelings
on it and how acceptable the behavior is has changed since then.
I don't know what the [__] I'm supposed to do about
that besides I don't think the behavior was really acceptable
back then. There's just no concept of really cancelling people.
that just didn't really exist on the internet and you guys weren't
really known enough. The internet wasn't like big enough that
everybody was like giving up on that level, right? Like 2012
we still have a lot of the population not significantly on the
internet, not significantly online. Is that is this just a thing
that like you want to bring up over and over again for reasons?
Um you can say that like I'm downplaying my actions because I
brought up that we were drunk or whatever. I mean like Mia has
said the exact same thing. This was years ago. I chocked it up
to being young. Everyone had too much to drink, but I wanted
to be around these people to get my name out. I know Dusty is
toxic, but I have no issues with him. I do have issues with him
spreading the wrong info like on Swifty. I think we were or I
said something about Swifty at this time 2020. I don't know what
was going on. Um, my subreddit literally brought up like the
whole excessive drinking thing. Destiny surrounded by drunks.
Egging him on. It would be nice of me, a rose would be a bro
since she's mostly sober, tells me to sleep, blah blah blah blah
blah. Just to be clear, this is no fault of hers. It just doesn't
blah blah blah. Okay. Right. Crazy drinking stream. I think this
is my first time getting intoxicated ever. Uh, not good though.
But I mean, I said as much. So, I don't understand when people
want to bring up like this thing over and over again. Like, I've
already said it's not good. I like I don't stand by it. Like,
I think it's a bad thing. Um, yeah. I'm not sure what I'm supposed
to say about that. Like, I' I've said that as much. I communicated
with Mia Rose privately. Um, oh Jesus, she just tweeted 11 hours
ago. I don't know how this work. I just want to put it out there
that the omni liberal did apologize to me wholeheartedly. Uh,
he did wholeheartedly. He was the only person actually answered
my phone call at twitch.com. Not all these other idiots that
were clout chasers. People make mistakes. They grow up and learn.
And I guess you just tweeted 11 hours. >> Uh yeah. So I
basically don't care about the M Rose thing. Like the M Rose
thing is there. Like I said, if if he's apologized for it, she's
forgiven him and they've both moved on. It doesn't seem like
you really have to hold that that highly. Uh I I don't know why
Ethan included this. It was like like Ethan kind of gets like
some blood in the water and he will include anything that he
thinks looks bad. Like he just tries to do all the things that
that look bad. Uh it's way more powerful when you're trying to
send a message to stay focused on the message, right? That's
what made Ryan Beard's video so great. This is a piece of Ryan
Beard's video, but it is a piece in a greater pattern. It's much
harder to dismiss as an accident or something that was apologized
for when you put it into the greater pattern. Yes. Jesus, this
again. It was like 15 years ago. I'm over it. Y'all should be,
too. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know what else I'm supposed
to say about this. Also, I also speak hyperbolically a lot, and
I know that it's epic and hilarious when you want to be good
faith, but then when you're not, you're going to take everything
literally. It was not 5 minutes of grow. I'm pretty sure it was
like 5 seconds. Not that that makes it good. Not that makes it
acceptable, but I wasn't literally sitting there hanging on her
for five minutes, okay, on the stream. But
so I I I literally have Wait, what? That makes it good. Not you're
going to take everything literally. It was not 5 minutes of growing.
I'm pretty sure it was like 5 seconds. Not that that makes it
good.
I think it was like more than that and like a lot of her going,
"No, stop. Please stop. Please, please, please stop. Please don't
do that." It's an incredibly uncomfortable watch.
It's I don't know why he has to throw that little bit in at the
end. He was responding very well. And then he's like, "But it
wasn't like that bad." No, it was really bad actually. Like go
watch that uncut on your stream and tell me what your audience
thinks. It's rough. It is a rough watch. Now that makes it acceptable,
but I wasn't literally sitting there hanging on her for five
minutes, okay, on the stream. But
so I I I literally have no idea what I'm what else I'm supposed
to do about this or what I'm supposed to say about this other
than good job. I guess that's so pattern one. Okay. 14 years
ago 2011. Okay. First part of the pattern. All right. Oh, I see.
So he's going to talk about patterns and stuff. This is Oh, he's
going to try to pretend that this is a I I already had this I
had this thought cuz if you didn't see Carrier in here complaining
saying, "Oh, he responded to the Ryan Beard video via Ethan Klein."
Ethan Klein doesn't transmute, sorry, he doesn't transmit the
meaning of the Ryan Beard video even a little bit. But Destiny's
going to say, "Well, I don't have to respond to the Ryan Beard
video because I responded to Ethan Klein butchering it." >> That's
far from the worst thing I'm about to say.
>> Far from the worst. It gets way worse from here, guys.
Uh here's the next one where he uh admits to sharing photos of
a 15-year-old who sent him bikini shots with his homies and how
he couldn't resist barely resist the urge of wanting
>> Destiny was 23. He shared in a group chat with a couple
of his friends the messages, you want to see the sickest [__]
in the world. So many fan girls. I had one that was 15. She wanted
to meet and hook up. Dude, she's 15. What the? But she sent me
pictures that made it so hard to say no.
>> Okay. Made it so hard to say no. That's a tough one
to respond to. >> Then Destiny linked a picture of this
girl in a bikini in the chat and said, "Girl on the left. So
hard to say no. Going to get arrested. One of these MLGs, man."
So, in these logs, when Destiny was 23, he said that it was really
hard to turn down hooking up with this 15-year-old because she
looked so good in this picture of her in a bikini. He then shared
this lewd image of a child with his friends and said that he's
going to get arrested someday.
That's uh that's tough to come back from. Okay, that's tough
to contextualize in a way that doesn't make you sound like a
total crazy. receiving a bikini pick from a 15-year-old in your
DMs, a fan of yours, and being like, "She's so hot. I need to
share this with the boys." >> Chat log, I was talking with
a bunch of other esports guys, and we were basically talking
about how crazy the jailbait is in the gaming communities. It's
ridiculous. I think I said something along the lines of like,
"There are 15-year-old chick." Dude, if he can play this off
as a joke to people, then he can convince people of anything,
right? He can convince people of anything. He's not joking. He
went on to the Medicare like Medicare Warski Tonkasaw stream
and like triple quadruple quintupled down on this right like
he is make no mistake he says yes this 15-year-old was hot yes
I said I would I understood that it was wrong to
like he it's not a joke he was not joking about the things he's
saying >> chicks that are like hot as that will like try
to send you pictures to like you at events and [__]
and it's like you have to be really careful when you navigate
that >> so what is the admitting to >> where I just
want the part of the log where he says, "Is is there a missing
piece of the log that says, "Guys, you got to be really careful
navigating this." Cuz even back here, he's trying to massage
what he actually said. Right? The the part where he's like, "Oh,
you guys got to be careful navigating that." That doesn't exist.
That's like entirely, as far as I can tell, entirely fabricated,
right? Want to see the sickest in the world. So many fan girls.
I had one that was 15. She wanted to meet and hook up. Dude,
she's 15. What the? But she sent me pictures that made it so
hard to say no. Look at this picture. Girl on the left. So hard
to say no. Going to get arrested one of these MLGs, man. Where
is he saying, "Guys, I just want a PSA that like you shouldn't
do that." He's just going, "Look at this hot girl. Look at this
hot girl." He's just bragging. He's just bragging. Unless there's
a log here that says something about him going, "Oh, actually
guys, just so you know, you shouldn't do this. Just so you know,
this is bad." >> Off to 15year-olds. And what is that in
>> I never admitted to I think I just said like this. I
think the log is something like this 15-year-old chick was trying
to send me or was sending me pictures of herself and she was
hot as [__] It's like I didn't say it jerk off to
it. Well, you said it was attractive. So much so that despite
knowing her age,
the pictures were so hot that it made hard it made it hard to
say no.
Dude, she's 15, but she sent me pictures that made it so hard
to say no.
As in, I knew it was wrong to try to 15-year-old, but I had to
exercise enormous self-control to say no. Right. And to be clear,
I could believe that this was a joke if it all led to some joke,
but he doesn't appear to be leading to a joke, does he? Like
really hard to like turn down some of these people. I think I
>> Wait, how old was she? >> Um, she said she was
15. >> So, you did get pictures from a >> Not nudes,
though. Sorry, I should specify. I think a couple pics of her
like at the beach or some but um >> in swimwear. >> Yeah.
Yeah. So, you're getting swimmer picks for 15year-olds. >> Yeah.
Hell yeah, dude. >> That's crazy. That's cra I'm sorry,
guys. Anyone who's defending this man needs to know that. Okay.
But again,
>> hell yeah, dude. >> Hell yeah. Timeline. This
is 2012. Okay. 13 years ago when I was 23. I feel like if the
goal is to say that I'm a >> That's not the goal. That's
not my goal. At least No, that's not really laughing that clip.
Just to be clear, the only person's goal who that seems to be
is Ethan's, which is why he's responding to Ethan, right? >> It
feels kind of weird that I wouldn't a 15-year-old. I'm just saying
if the argument is going to be that I'm a Wouldn't I be posing
saying like, "Look at this hot 15-year-old jailbait that I hooked
up." Wouldn't that be the the statement or whatever? But regardless,
no ped. He He's totally aware that it's not the Listen, if it
was a prepubescent child, he's totally aware that is not the
act, it's the attraction. and he is describing the attraction.
The attraction is almost so overwhelming that it overrides his
ability to follow the law and he knows that. So, it's really
weird that he's like totally misunderstanding that, misconring
it here, right?
Um, back in the day, for anybody that was alive or back there,
uh, in the in the crazy gaming times, um, MLG events were literally
cesspools of crazy of fans and creators hooking up, of fans and
fans hooking up, creators and creators hooking up, people getting
raped, people getting drugged, people doing drugs.
I don't care about other people. I don't know who any of those
people are. If you if he wants to name some of those people or
talk about it, right, then we could talk about it. You can't
just say, "Guys, you don't understand. Everybody was doing crazy
back then, and I'm not going to talk about anybody who did it,
but you have to stop criticizing me for it." How does that make
any sense, guys? Everybody back then was doing crazy. You have
no idea. It's like, "Okay, just talk about it then. That can't
be an out for you." That's not like, "Oh, well, I guess I guess
these comments on the 15-year-old, we let those slide cuz other
people were doing crazy [__] at MLG in 2012. People
was just crazy crazy." And one of the issues back then as well
because everybody involved in pro gaming was so young. Um, and
I think even actually that might even be true today. I don't
know how young people are today. Like everybody is literally
like 14 to 22 at these events. Um, it's just like all sorts of
people that are going here. And one of the things is people would
message you, people DM you obviously if you were a big streamer,
if you were a big player and they would send you pictures like,
"Hey, would you blah blah blah?" And at the time I think there
were people who were getting in trouble for hooking with underage
people. Yeah. I messaged my
>> I think the Stefano thing takes place way after that
or whatever. Obviously those DMs were pretty crass. But I mean
the whole point is like hey like there are going to be people
that DM you. They'll send you pictures. They look older than
they actually are. Don't minor. Your life is going to be over.
Don't That's not Can I get the Can I get Are there further logs
where he says anything like this? He's just lying.
He's He's literally just lying here, right? We could just read
the logs again. Guys, guys, don't mind her or your life would
be over. So hard to say no. Gonna get arrested one of these MLGs,
man.
Dude, she's 15, but she sent me pictures that made it so hard
to say no. He's translated this now fully into Guys, don't [__]
Miner. Your life will be over. Guys, watch out guys. Watch out.
Don't [__] Miner or your life will be over. I'm totally
not making it seem cool and funny and like that. I'm super attracted
to these 15-year-olds. This is just like him openly lying. Um,
anybody who buys that, like Jesus Christ,
I that's rough. Do it. If you want to like sit here and virtue
signal about how, oh no, like every single person above or below
this age, like the second they turn 18 or 22, they instantly
look attractive or like this. I'm not here for that. If that's
what you want to do, then go for it. Um, why would that matter?
I thought you were just warning them that, hey, there are 15year-olds
out here who look older and and don't go to jail. Were you commenting
on how hot they were? I would never know that from your previous
statement. But I mean, yeah, the again, I don't know why I would
not a person if I'm a or maybe I maybe Ethan's argument is going
to be that I become a later on in life and I wasn't back then.
But yeah,
um also these are people who when they by the time I learn my
age, typically they would message you, send you a pick or whatever.
By the time I learn their age, I stopped talking to this person,
right? It's not like, "Oh my god, I continue to talk to this
person after I found out they're 15." It's like they
>> Oh, did he to he totally cut that relationship off at
that 15-year-old who was sending the swimbar and and he
ah the other thing would be wait which did he receive first the
picture of the swimwear or the age. That's something you could
never know. Honestly, I don't think I'd trust any answer that
wasn't like pulled from Instagram DMs or something. Chad you
go up for a little bit like wait a second. How old are you? And
they're like oh I'm 15 16 17 like oh nope. Okay well don't talk
to this person. Yeah I've never received also
>> done talking to this person. Why would you be done talking
to that person? Why would you be done talking to that person?
You take their pictures, you dump them in your group chat and
go, "Guys, look how hot this 15-year-old
>> Dudes or any crazy thing like this? Like I think the
thing I said was like a beach picture. Somebody on the beach.
This is like an in I don't know if it was Instagram back then
if that existed, but um yeah. But okay,
that's not it. That's not all folks. Here's another one. When
he was 26. A couple years later in 2015 when Destiny was 26,
he shared in his chat, "I would the out of that 15year-old. What
the? There's no way that chick is 15." So now we Uh-huh.
Interesting.
Now
that could be a joke. Okay, that could be a joke. You have to
see the context. But again, we we start to see like the jokes
get colored a little bit by by future evidence, right? You find
it's like the method Josh conundrum. You guys, anyone got that
method Josh graph video? Method Josh graph
joking. Can we do we have that video? Do I have that? Do I have
that video somewhere of him >> and was like, "Dude, why
did you unmod me?" Um, it's >> Oh, no, no, no. That's not
it. Hold on. I'm looking for this Method. You guys know the clip,
right? Method Josh doing the graphing of his own crazy where
he's like, "People think it's a Ah, here it is." Right. Here
it is.
That's what that is. Anyway, uh, so yeah, I got a few different
faults,
>> So, initially people think everything is fully serious
and then for some reason people end up thinking that this is
all some big meta joke and it's ironic and that I'm actually
happily married for 5 years and have a dog and I'm just pretending
to be a lonely angry virgin on the internet. And then as time
goes on, they realize that it actually all was serious and nothing
was a joke and that I need serious help. So, >> and for
us, that's when we realized that Destiny actually was somebody
dubiously aged that he couldn't confirm and that when he was
informed that she was a minor by the person he believes filmed
the videos, he actually kept the videos. Right. That's a that's
where like all of the previous jokes start to go, "Oh,
Wait, huh?" Right? Everything gets everything gets contextualized
in a way that you update your priors. you go, "Oh, I actually
might not have evaluated this correctly at all before. I actually
might be totally out to lunch on my read of this."
Now, even given that, I'm not sure I I would lean into the allegation
that Destiny's like an actual dictionary defined,
right? Where you'd have the primary attraction to prepubescent
kids. I wouldn't do that, right? But there is like there is a
colloquial usage of and that does mean people who try to [__]
minors and try to [__] kids, right? Like in general.
and he pretty objectively seems to have kept a lot of so I I
don't know you put all these things together man it's it doesn't
paint a a pretty >> we've seen two separate occasions >> guys
this is not normal you just don't type that kind of stuff unless
you're like Jared Fogle in a chat with his homies you know like
he's speaking openly with the dogs who are like yeah I know exactly
what you mean you would never say this is not normal and like
he keeps getting older and older >> yes that's that's how
time works I do indeed continue to get older, >> but the
girls stay the same age. >> He loves that joke. He said
this joke in like 50 different shows that I've watched at this
point. Um, >> my name is >> I'll leave it up for
you to decide if you think I genuinely am typing in my chat about
how hot this girl is and me wanting to her or if this is just
a crazy thing I'm saying in chat about some crazy clip posted
in chat. But I went back and I found what it was in chat and
this was it. >> My name is Victoria and I'm 15 years old
and I don't care what my mama says. I'm going to have a baby.
I will do whatever it takes to take care of my baby. If it happens
to positive in my body, then so be it. >> There's no way
that chick is 15. I would the [__] out of that 15-year-old.
What the uh Oh, sorry. Other way around. I would the [__]
out of that 15-year-old. What the [__] There's no
way that chick is 15. And he says, I'll I'll leave it up to you
to determine if this is a joke or not. >> I'm going to
dress my baby and all brand names. And if I can't support it,
then I guess I'm going to spill it. My mama thinks that I'm not
ready to have a baby, but I have everything my baby will need.
If my baby gets close and it needs a blanket, it's all right
cuz I have it. And if my baby needs clothes,
>> I I just feel like Do we believe Hold on. Do we believe
that this 15-year-old would look significantly different than
the one that it was so hard to say no to? Like I I'm sorry, but
I've seen I've seen the comments you've made before. I don't
know that that's a joke. I literally don't know. Like this is
a this is clearly like some over
girl who's got some issues, right? that she's on my talking about
how she wants to have a baby or some like clearly this is somebody
with issues. I man, >> it's cool. I have tons of them.
And if my pass, I have three more. I'm not just having sex with
one of them. And if my pass, I have three more. I'm not just
having sex with one, not two, but three different guys. That's
right. I'm a player. But that's cool cuz I got it like that.
My life is to drop out of school to be on girls.
>> I'm sorry. Does this
Okay, this is one of those moments where I'm like, is he totally
out of touch with reality? Is Has he completely lost touch of
with reality? So, he says when I made the joke that I would totally
[__] the [__] that 15year-old and there's
no way that chick is 15.
He's playing this clip and going, "Guys, doesn't it all make
sense now that it's obviously a joke?" I I think this only works
in his community. I think he has cultivated a community where
this can work that where this context lands and makes like somehow
absolves himself. and to have my baby and there's nothing my
super mother can say to change my >> Okay, so it could
have been a genuine confession for my urges or it could be an
edgy joke and is that urges? I thought you were just saying that
like, "Hey guys, I'm not going to deal with anybody who virtue
signals that as soon as someone turns 18 now they're viable and
you were discussing you wanted to this girl. Is this urges if
you wanted to that 15year-old?" Cuz what did he just give away
there? Apparently with this girl, it would be urges if he said
he wanted to [__] her seriously. But with this girl,
the MLG girl, she's 15 and he absolutely is saying seriously
he wants to [__] her. And he spent 5 hours preparing
this. By the way, this is this is after 5 hours of prep. >> I
don't know. Would that count for a bingo square? Oh, guys, I've
not been paying attention to the bingo. What would it be? What
would it be? Well, we'll see. >> Jordan Peterson
$5. Rest my case. He shows you exactly how evil he is and then
demands his cult views him as in the right. >> That seems
to be occurring, Mr. Peterson. Thank you very much for pointing
this out. Okay. We appreciate your expert insight into this.
Okay. I don't know if I see I don't know if I see that. Okay.
I don't know if I see that on any of these things here. We'll
keep going. >> You decide. Left side >> again. That's
not all, folks. >> Oh, every every single time I talk about
kids is a joke. Oh, you're right. Hold on. Every single time
I talk about kids, it's a joke. It's a joke, guys. It's just
a joke. >> But the colloquial definition of pedophile is
>> Oh, and then also, I guess for although I guess he's
building a pattern of behavior again, this was a joke in my chat
in 2015. Okay. But that's okay. We're building our We're building
our pattern. All right.
>> Wait, did Destiny change at some point? Does Destiny
not make jokes about 15year-olds
in ways anymore? Is that something he stopped doing? Can we find
uh can we find a significant period of time where he stopped
doing those jokes or cuz that's what he just suggested, right
guys? They're trying to build a pattern of behavior and this
is from 2015.
So, he stopped. That's not all folks.
But the colloquial definition of is someone who is attracted
to children and destiny is at least somewhat attracted to children.
There are some 15 16 year old chicks that like look pretty like
I can't I can't help that. Like some people mature older >> destiny
def. >> Okay. So again you can have issues with what I'm
saying but definitionally I'm literally talking about people
that look older than 15 16. Not teenagers are hot. I love teenagers
but some 15 16 year olds can look older. That's the opposite
of but listen if that's what you want to say that's fine. Okay,
we'll keep going through it. >> He's really mixing this
up. He's He's really mixing this up,
right? He is doing the technical definition thing here as well.
>> Another streamer who got
some 15-year-olds look hot to me. Yeah. Well, that's what he's
saying. But he just said that clearly he he said, "Oh, well,
I guess this would be like a confession of if I did want to that
15-year-old." That's what he said before, right? He's like totally
mixing his messages. exposed for having with a 14-year-old by
saying even if he did bang a 14-year-old, no, that's not what
means. Go look it up. Seriously, if you don't understand the
difference between being attracted to someone that happens to
be young and being attracted to someone because they are young,
you have absolutely no business. Hold on. I can't believe he
didn't pull the feeble line or whatever. He didn't pull it cuz
Beard makes fun of him for it. He did pull it quite literally
though. He said this isn't what is. When he says this isn't what
is, he just doesn't want to do the normal track record, the normal
line of like going into the definitions, strict definitions,
but it is what he's saying. He's just like dog whistling at it.
>> Whatsoever commenting on the issue, period. It makes
you look unanimated. I >> He's like, "It is so outrageous,
sir, that you would call someone sleeping with a 14-year-old.
How dare you, sir.
Even if you want to play this game where it's like, actually,
actually, I want to [__] >> your pig."
Reban Ruben $3. >> The real question is why is Ryan beard
so clean shaven?
>> I have no idea, but thank you for the three. Revenubin
Woo he says these comments are like from 2015. You were friends
with him how long ago? Uh one, when I started watching them,
I had no idea these clips existed. But two, okay, two, even when
I did realize they existed, they seem like obvious jokes to me.
As we've discussed multiple times, this all seemed like jokes,
jokes, jokes. And then you find out that despite being able to
define how important it is to stay away from the line of crossing
over to have sex interactions with the minor, he has now done
that pretty explicitly with reckless abandon in a way that makes
me re-evaluate my priors when I thought these were jokes before.
Now they look a little weird to me. Right now they look a little
weird. So you're okay with people making those jokes? I'm okay
with people making those jokes sometimes when they can make them
and they're contextually appropriate. Right? I'm a little weirded
out by a guy who has credible allegations that he's created a
giant stash of
right and that has had relationships with minors has described
minors in as low as 15 as almost too hot to refuse
with that guy. I'm like, "Ah, I feel really uneasy." Right? This
is the same concept as when you are joking about like you're
doing joking racism with people you know aren't racist and then
you end up hearing like a racist start doing like actual racism
and you're like, "Oh, it's like not funny anymore cuz I know
you like actually believe." It's like it's it changes the context
entirely, right? We all are able to identify these things. I
think we all understand these things, right? That like when when
somebody's like just expressing real racism, you're like, "Uh."
And now I've got like some evidence that's come out that makes
me go, "Oh, I actually don't think Destiny should be making these
jokes at all. They're uh ah that's yikes, dude. That's a yikes."
16 and 17 year olds. Um there's 14 is pushing it. 14? What are
we talking about? This man was like, "Yeah, you can 14-year-old.
That's that's not the same thing,
>> I don't know if I've I don't think I've ever said that
ever." But >> are we all hearing the same thing? >> It's
14. This dude has made it like his personal crusade to normalize
children. Like how many That's a again he he's going he's going
overboard. He's being hyperbolic. And Desessie's favorite thing
talked about this a lot is when he has a opponent who's going
to be hyperbolic, right? Because he can virtue signal. He can
soy the out over hyperbole better than anybody who exists on
the internet. If you go one step over the line with Destiny,
he will soy the [__] out about this. You'll you'll
have his audience entirely on his side, right? because you you've
you've transgressed against destiny. You've you've gone one iota
over the line against destiny. It doesn't matter how hyperbolic
he is about everybody else. Doesn't matter at all, right? And
he's got a big cult behind him who will lose their [__]
the second you go hyperbolic slightly. Wild statement to say
based off what we've seen so far. Um I did go back and I found
the post for this cuz I was curious. I think I made an OP here
that basically has to do um >> it basically has to do with
like uh streaming is a little bit different and crazy because
you have so much access in people's lives you don't traditionally
get. At the bottom of this example, one of the incidents that
I brought up was um this guy Stefano got in trouble cuz he was
19 and he DM' some player saying that he abused a 14-year-old
and everybody took that as he him because this guy's French.
Um not because their abuses but because of a ESL thing. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Can someone find
the the truth of this? Cuz I could have sworn that the guy is
streaming who Stefano is messaging and he explicitly says, "Do
you mean you had with him?" And he says like, "Yes." I didn't
think it was just I abused a minor. I thought it was literally
that he had had sex with them.
Am I wrong? I don't think that's even doubted. Why is Desi lying
about that now? Um, I literally state at the bottom here, I'm
not taking a side on any of these issues or commenting that's
happened. I'm just giving food for thought about like the level
of access that you have to people's lives here. I was never defending
this in this post. I'm not defending this anywhere. Um I think
I like Yeah, I was an edgy like internet atheist. I didn't I
didn't defend this at all. Even if he did bang a 14-year-old,
no, that's not what means. Go look it up. That's that's his post
right there. I'm not defending this. Seriously, if you don't
understand the difference between being attracted to someone
that happens to be young and being attracted to someone because
they're young, you have absolutely no business whatsoever commenting
on the issue. Period. It makes you look uneducated. Also, lol.
a powerful ally, safe zone, positive community that demonizes
even self- admitted who are seeking help. Like he is absolutely
I'm sorry. Yes, normalizing. Sure. I think he's saying like is
this really crazy? Is this really It's not like Whoa, don't be
hyperbolic about this. That would be that would be the worst
thing you could do is be hyperbolic about what Stefano's done
here. And we did the if you don't understand between being attracted
to someone that happens to be young and being attracted to someone
because they're young. Um the difference between whatever the
[__] else. I will say that if like if that's like
a creepy thing that people are doing to advocate for um I guess
like >> you haven't seen this girl for a month. >> Around
a month. Yeah. >> Do you love her?
>> Brand new sex.
>> Uh-oh. Are we going to get a clip where Ethan says something
off color? Uh-oh.
>> Guys, I want you to know that Ethan could have an opinion
here that makes Destiny keeping all of that from Rose a little
better. It could cast it in a different light. I'm sure Ethan's
opinion, the words he says will make that act seem better, right?
>> She's 17,
>> Hell yeah, Brandon. What's up? >> What? Anyway,
>> she to Jason's party cuz she wasn't 18. Like, I knew
about this. That's when I distanced myself. And Jason would always
be at me that I wouldn't film with Brandon. I'm like, he's an
actual like and we're actually like and he's like >> Having
sex with a seven turn isn't
>> for sure with a minor for sure was that's an actual
like it's a child. 17-year-old is a child. >> So, okay,
whatever. I don't need to debate that. But it's a
>> Ethan's biggest mistake here, and you'll notice this
in his previous post, okay? Was that at this point he was a Destiny
fan, okay? Oh, yes. Ethan Trisha clip. Oh, there it is. Cuz I
I knew this clip existed and I knew this clip was going to come
out as if this could defend Destiny from something.
Let's see. Ethan Trisha clip. It's gone. It's off the board,
guys. It's off the board.
um had a
someone that has with kids. >> She's a child. That's a
child. >> But you don't magically become not a child when
you go turn from when the clock ticks midnight. >> That
actually is like how it works. Yeah. Like you also have no business
being like an 18-year-old, but like 17 is an actual child. You're
actually it's actually legal. Like you actually should go to
jail.
>> Okay. I'm not here to debate that. But some states it's
16. >> But it's not that in California. >> No, it's
illegal. It's f So I mean like if that's if that it's illegal.
Yeah. It's illegal.
Okay. So, he's making a legal argument. So, how does that how
is that going to save us from anything >> Like, ar back
back then he's making a legal argument, right? >> Defending
trying to kids that maybe me and Ethan are just
born to justify it. I I don't know. >> Many times are you
going to go on the record protecting it? He goes 17 is cool.
15 is cool. >> Never said either of those things. >> 14
is >> haven't said that. >> Not ped.
Uh he's saying 15 is the attraction. Again, the the the attraction
is what you're talking about here, not the acts, right?
Um and Ethan's accusation seems to be normalizing kids. So when
Destiny says is the influencer, guys, I find these 15-year-olds
so hot. When Destiny says that, right, that is starting to normalize
in that direction. Now, is he aware of that back then? I don't
know. But I Ethan's not making like the worst argument in the
world. I just wouldn't make it. I don't think the evidence is
there to make like the argument he's trying to make super strongly.
Um I think he's gone a little overboard in what he's going to
allege here and it's going to let Destiny weasel pretty hard
to feel you guys is 13. So there's >> haven't said any
like
>> Not sure if this is his own fantasy that he's projecting
on me or
>> where does it stop? >> Oh that would have been
perfect for bingo. Oh, why is he projecting this onto me? Why
is he making this thing up? Isn't Is Ethan thinking about me
having with minors right now? Is that all that's in his head?
Is Ethan having Ethan's dreaming about me having with minors?
Is that what he's thinking >> I'd like to know his opinion
on that. You know, a lot of people kids start hitting puberty
at 12. Some girls start hitting puberty earlier than that. Is
10. Some girls hit puberty by 10. Is that not Stephen Benell
the second? By the way, the second is just junior. Okay. You
don't have you don't get to play the the >> the second
is not junior. They are different on your birth certificate.
I the reason why I'm not junior is because my dad just didn't
want to be called senior. So he wrote mine in as the second so
he could be the first. I'm sorry if that bothers you but >> royal
guard game with just being the second. In fact, that's just junior,
which ironically is what you call the girls you play.
Come on over here, Junior. Come sit in daddy's lap.
>> Another
one again. >> Yeah, but guess what, guys? >> I'm
sorry. If you want to not have jokes made about you, stop talking
about [__] kids. Stop children,
stop getting caught
minors. It's that easy. It's that easy. If you don't want people
to laugh at you and joke about you being a
stop giving them all the ammunition in the world, stop rage baiting
about yourself being a If Pearly Things came out tomorrow and
said, "Guys, I've been a feminist the whole time and I was just
joking and people still make fun of her for red pill opinions,
that's not going to be a problem." Okay, that's sorry, just pearly
things. You we're going to make fun of you for the stupid things
you said all that time. If you're going to rage bait with jokes,
jokes about you being jokes about you kids, jokes about how hot
kids are, jokes about kids off to If you're going to do all of
these things, Destiny, then don't get mad when people call you
a
Okay,
don't performatively get angry and people call you a [__]
you.
There's more is when him and his friends, the bro squad, watched
an 8-year-old boy shake his for them on a live stream. >> I
shouldn't tell this because I'm going to get [__]
arrested. um for child protective services. >> By the way,
how many times has he said that? Once is enough. Has he said
this like three times? He's like, I shouldn't tell you guys this
cuz I'm going to get arrested for child.
>> Three. How many times are we going to tell that joke?
>> I haven't gotten into Ethan's jokes yet, but I do think
it's kind of funny that I feel like I've heard him say so. By
the way, Private Huff, Destiny would totally agree with this.
This is the exact point about when it's not funny anymore. when
a real racist or real homophobe is engaging in homophobic jokes
with you or racist jokes with you, right? That like, hey, these
like these jokes about kids, maybe they work in some context.
They don't work in the context of you have actual charges or
you're incredibly accused of maintaining a stash of child.
Now they don't work anymore.
They don't work at all. >> Similar things. >> It's
called Children's Joy TV for a reason. The guy knows how to give
pleasure children. Children's Joy TV. baby gets by a syringe
and gets injected with AIDS virus. >> When we see something
like this, are we supposed to call the police? >> Am I
on a I feel like I'm definitely on the FBI watch list now.
>> I don't know. Is that a So this video where they are
saying this is bad
is is Destiny saying that all he's saying is that it's bad that
this happened. That's not what he's saying. He's laughing about
it. Is Ethan laughing? What do we What's the equivalence here?
How many FBI watch
Destiny can Can Destiny for the love of
This is this is going to be so pathetic if this is the way he
goes down like like absolutely totally failing to put these Can
you just start paying people? Can you start paying researchers?
I understand Andy B is taking a lot of your money right now,
but can you start paying researchers? start paying researchers
who have some cultural understanding to do this stuff for you
because I swear to God if you keep hiring like bot farms or like
like sweat shops in India to commission out for all of your research,
you're going to get that kind of quality of clip. You're going to
make horrible points. Okay? And it's really embarrassing cuz
a lot of us thought you were compelling at some point. So please
stop embarrassing us by doing such a poor job of defending >> jokes
he's made. Maybe he is, maybe he isn't. If again if like that's
the standard then sure. >> We used to be part of this horrible
thing called the bro squad. Okay. Me if you remember that
and
a long time ago. Oh my [__] god. >> Part of
the bro squad and what we do is we would go around Justin TV
streams trolling the [__] channel to channel like
it was horrible. We went to this channel with this like this
kid was like 8 years old and he was [__] broing out
with everybody in this chat recently. This kid decides to [__]
take his pants off and wiggle his 8-year-old dick on his stream.
I can't even believe it. Oh my god. It was like I didn't even
know like we were on Skype. We were like, "Holy shit." Like we
had to do like a double take cuz we didn't even know like what
the [__] was like looking at like an 8-year-old dick
on the screen and brother and his >> Where's the Where's
the Oh, this is disturbing. This is awful. This is horrifying.
Where is that part of this? Like there was for Ethan's clip.
Where's that part of it? Where did that go? He's literally laughing
now. >> We call him Captain Push-ups. Would like come in
the room and this guy was like [__] 14 years old.
He had his shirt off and he was like this like watching the stream
the entire time and [__] Oh my god. What's interesting
is he makes it seem like this kid just happened to take his dick
out, but they clearly spent a lot of time there cuz they like
had a nickname for the brother who was there watching the whole
time. Like this was a this was an intimate setting in which there
was a lot of time spent. >> Okay. So again, I don't know
why Ethan projects his own fantasies onto this. Um, so >> did
they come up with the name Captain Push-Ups the first time that
they watched this or like the guy walked into the room one time
and they made that name up and then they were like he remembers
that affectionately or >> this was a thing that happened
back in 2010 which is 15 years ago. Um, but that why dude I killed
that person back in 1995. So like why are you pretending that
matters now? I killed a girl in
like Bob Saga did. Okay. And what why would that be a big deal
now? Why are you bringing that up as if that matters? Excuse
me.
That was in that was in 1995. That doesn't matter at all. I I
we want to go back. That's fine. Um I will say in the early days
of live streaming, live stream websites were literally the wild
west of crazy unhinged me and a few other people. Plenty of people
would bounce between you stream live stream Justin TV. And you
could find old dudes doing conspiracy theories. You could find
people doing self harm. You could find copyright uh material
being played. You could find just like a bunch of
Are we going to count that, guys? Does that go on the board?
This is unhinged.
This is just wild and unhinged stuff, man. Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? Where is it? Unhinged. Unhinged. Unhinged.
Why don't I see it? I know it's here. I know. I put it on here.
Where is it? This is unhinged.
Thank you. This is unhinged. Crazy. This is a We popped into
this dude's stream. We were trolling in chat for a little bit.
Nobody is saying like, "Oh my god, yes." Like, "Take your what,
you know, whatever the Ethan is fantasizing here." There were
no long-term relations with any of these people. It was a crazy
thing that happened. We left the stream immediately after. Um
I don't know why he likes to project whatever other I think it's
totally reasonable to think you were there a couple times. His
brother would come into the room and put his What do you mean
that you're talking about something that happened more than once,
right? You're describing a behavior that has happened more than
one time. I'm right. If if it was a singles time story, you say,
"So we this one time we found this kid and this happened and
then the brother came into the room." You don't say his brother
would come into the room and just like hold his arms like this.
I not that like you could prove any of this. So maybe not that
like it matters all that much, but to me it seems very clear
that this was like a persistent thing that was happening. Fantasy
of spending a lot of time there or getting to and I would just
say look at the culture of DG. Look at the internet culture in
general. If you found something funny, let's say, let's say I
have no doubt that when this kid pulled his dick out, they didn't
go back to the channel. But let's say that they found this kid
and this kid was funny and they would like tell this kid weird
[__] They'd be like, "Don't you know about like uh
Meat Spin or some shit." They'd like, "Oh, [__] this
kid." In a gross way, okay, in a totally gross way. And then
they would go back if if it was like a log they found. That's
You go back. You absolutely go back. That happened to DG after
the fact. You find like a low viewer streamer that DG would watch.
I don't know. This is like there's this weird line going around
and you'll never be able to prove anything. So, it's like whatever.
Who cares about most of this stuff? >> I know the person.
Maybe he's done trolling like this in the past. I'm not aware
of. But
>> here's another one, guys. In case you know, you haven't
seen enough. This one comes to you courtesy of the Pope, uh,
Nicholas Dioro. >> What's up, General? >> Whatever
it is, they do. >> Oh, this is the one. This is the one
Ethan gets really wrong. This is the one Ethan really up.
Ah, enjoy this. >> Nicholas Bless years old. That's an
adult. That's an adult dog. No.
No, no you. Okay, I'm 29. A 19-year-old might as well be a 15-year-old
to me. It's okay. That's that's that's the wor that's the worst.
Yeah, that's the worst clip. That's No, that's the worst clip.
>> Okay, I'm 29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15-year-old
to me. It's all the same, dude. Yo, don't give me this. Just
>> that's such an interesting. >> This is exactly
what we're saying. >> It's all the same, bro. 15, 13, 14,
15. It's all the same, bro. I'm 29. But also
I I just look forward to it because the way Ethan's misunderstanding
it, it's like gonna require Desi responding. And then you realize
that as he ages, he also starts dating and marries Molina, who
was 19 when they met for the first time, purportedly 18 when
they started >> On the other hand, also is um a self-report
because it suggests he knows exactly what he's doing. >> Yeah.
I don't even know what that means when he says it knows exactly
what I'm doing. So, this is a clip that gets thrown a lot around
a lot because people like to say that the apparently everybody
below 20 I view the exact same. Um, that is one voice cut from
that debate. Uh, if you listen to the actual debate here, I'm
arguing with a dude who is literally trying to abduct a mentally
19year-old and take her to another state and impregnate her.
Basically, every other time I'm speaking about this person and
their age. I do refer to the fact they're 19, but it's not just
the fact they're 19. It's a whole bunch of other things, too.
Um,
>> it's not there, but let's say 19-year-old girl communicated
with him online. He fell in love with her. He convinced her to
leave her family and join him. And then after 3 weeks of being
with her, a girl that had never lived on her own, worked a job,
lived apart from her parents, been in a relationship, he convinced
her to try to have a child with him. >> First, I would
say,
>> why does he keep jumping around you? >> Sure,
you don't have to care about my moral offense because the court
already agreed with me about the moral offense. She had never
lived on her own before and despite all of this, you convinced
her to leave her family without a without a word to join you.
By the way, just like Molina, like Molina, like
except that kid part, but sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. Molina
had lived on her own. Molina, no, Molina was living on her own
in New Zealand. It's a little different. Okay, it's a little
different. It's a little different. It's a little different.
It's a little different. All right,
I'm just going to laugh about JF here because I don't think this
is Mama JF they're referring to, right? I think this is JF's
first wife,
right? This is not JF's second wife, Mama JF. I believe there's
a first wife that came first, right? Am I Am I W Am I crazy?
I'm pretty sure this this is a different This is a different
woman. I'm almost positive this is a different woman. Which one
do you Mama JF? She came later. Yes. Yes. This is a different
woman that he met on the internet. Okay. >> And make a
baby. >> That's called love, you idiot. >> That's
called love. A 19-year-old girl. Yeah, a 19-year-old girl can
love you, idiot. You want people in the future to be scared of
going out with mentally disabled people. Eventually, destiny
will find out and he will ruin their life. Now, it is a 19year-old
woman who was free to make her choices. Steven can come here
and express moral offense. Who cares? Everyone in the chat says
19 is legal, Steven. >> So, why didn't she fight the court
about being appointed a guardian, JF, if she wanted to? >> She
was intimidated, physically abused by her father and intimidated
into abandoning her rights. >> You're saying that a girl
was so easily intimidated that she quickly gave up her right
to exist on autonomous person. But you claim the same person
was mature enough to make the decision to move in with you and
bear your child. >> The reality is that >> like there's
a lot in this debate. It was not just that the fact that this
girl was 19. This girl was
>> okay. Why
he can say this, but like where is that laid out is a part of
his
>> Was declared mentally incompetent by a court and then
her parents prevented her from being abducted by this guy. >> Yeah.
All of these are from that same debate by the way.
>> Or because when you live with somebody it's a totally
different thing. So somebody tells me that they're in love with
somebody that they've been talking to online and then they up
and just leave their family with no word and they just drive
cross country and in a few weeks are trying to create a child
with this person without a financial future without any type
of financial security. Yeah, that's a there's a red flags there.
Apparently, she was intelligent enough to find a guy who wanted
to care for her for the rest of his life and who had the amount
of money required to survive for that long. And so, go get [__]
moral
people watching live should hear his point of view about her
life. >> And here we have JF, the 32-year-old man thrice
married who has found true love by talking to a 19-year-old mentally
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Maybe this is Mama
JF. Hold on. Maybe it is Mama JF cuz it's four marriages. Maybe
this was Mama JF. Maybe >> disabled girl who saw him on
a podcast and messaged him on Skype and after a few months he's
determined that she is his soulmate and he wants to ship her
off to North Carolina to put a baby in >> And that's biology.
I'm sorry you have a >> Yeah, biology.
>> If this was just love, I honestly wouldn't care as much.
It was that um JF was trying to do like unstoppable damage, like
permanent damage to her life by having a child with her. That's
more than just love. If they were just living together or whatever
and then the father showed up, like that's an entirely different
situation. It's the fact that after living with her for a few
weeks, Jeb is trying to get her pregnant. This is a girl that
never even lived on her own before. He thinks she could take
care of a kid. That's >> I'm assuming people that have
ever watched us debate like to pretend that I was just screaming
like 19 19. But there was way way way more going on. I'd say
the the kid thing, although it doesn't get him away from the
19th thing, which he is screaming about, and I don't I'm not
going to let him get off with that. Okay. That that you you know
exactly what you're saying. He's so specific in what he says
most of the time. But this does get him off uh in terms of the
Molina charge. Okay. He He can't be. So, I think the Oh, well,
not It wasn't just that you wanted to live with her. It was the
So, the comparison to Mina maybe not quite as effective. >> You
can rip one clip from it if you want, but
>> from a guy heading to a bar and buying a chick drinks
and then paying for dinner and then like buying her a bunch of
presents and treating her very well. It's the same thing, man.
>> It's not No, no, no. There's a huge difference. It's
the difference between consent versus informed consent that the
woman at the bar is a mature adult that has the mental faculty
to make decisions about her future. a mentally 19-year-old that
this particular one apparently according to two psychiatrists
ruled that she did not have the faculty to make this decision.
I'm curious how would you feel about a 17-y old girl doing this?
>> Like he's trying to get out of the 19-year-old can someone
explain how you get out of the 19-year-old um and 15year-old
clip. How do you add the mental what he's talking about for him?
He's saying I'm I'm 30. I'm 29. A 19-year-old might as well be
a 15year-old to me. Is he talking about his own attraction to
women like to actual mental?
I don't think I actually think that clip just stands on its own,
right? He's not like he can talk about the rest of this debate,
but he is making a moral statement of his own that stands on
its >> Uh it depends on what >> how would you feel
about a 15-year-old girl doing this? >> No, I have a problem
because it's now >> So the only thing that matters to you
is the law. Let's say we get rid of the law and we're just talking
morality. How would you feel about JF doing this with a 15-y
old girl? >> I would be very opposed to that. It's disgusting
in my opinion. But however, however, I know what you're going
to say. I know what you're going to say because what if this
girl was 30 but her mental state stayed as a like as let's say
a 14-year-old. So don't let her do >> That's what we do.
Yeah, Annie, there are people that old who are appointed guardians
for their entire lives because they're not mentally capable of
living on their own. And if they do live on their own No, it's
not inhumane. We do this to prevent other people from taking
advantage of them. >> But okay, I I guess you can >> Why
didn't he Why didn't he let it keep rolling? Hold on. Why didn't
he let it keep rolling? I have a feeling.
So, he played all of that within the the context of that is him
trying to say I'm really just talking about I'm not talking about
regular people. So, when I say a 19-year-old might as well be
a 15-year-old, that's all I'm saying. I don't think that's what
he's saying at all. And I'd love if somebody watched from where
he left off in this debate and to see if he actually differentiates
cuz I think he was about to say some that totally cuts against
everything he presented, but I'm not totally sure. Um,
should we do that right now? It's called love you idiot. You
You idiot. Destiny debate. It's called love, you idiot. >> I
don't care about
guardians for their entire lives because >> Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, is that the end of the is that the end of the video? Oh,
no.
There's no way. >> You mean we do this to prevent other
people from taking advantage of them? This is what you're asking
me to accept. That she secretly loved JF. Okay. That she wanted
to be with him. Hold on. People living on their own. And if they
do live on their own, no, it's not. >> That debate was
about me arguing that >> other people from taking advantage
of >> There's uh that's where >> but she was scared
of telling any law enforcement officer. She was scared of telling
either psychiatrist. She was scared of communicating this with
the judge. She didn't tell a single person. But but somehow she
had this secret >> I have no more interest in interacting
with Destiny on this.
>> Andy, don't date. >> Where's the rest of that
clip? Is the Is the actual clip here?
Hold on. 15
15 might as well. Is that not in the Is that not in the transcript?
Oh, is that is that part of the video just not here? Like 19
might as well be 15 to me. I just don't see that in the transcript
of this. Maybe it's just not in this part of the video. Maybe
it's in
Where's the rest of the video here? We'll debate in the description.
Let's
>> Okay, hold on. Full debate in the description. Okay.
Uh 15. How would you feel about a 17-year-old girl doing this?
uh depends on what uh >> okay so let's see the whole thing
he sets up here is about the mental listen to no support network
now she has his baby okay she has no job right she has no real
education right she's totally locked there and she's his that
is disgusting okay and that's kind of why like the fact that
he still defends this behavior is really irritating to me because
what he did was horrible that kind of is literally disgusting
that he would try to trap app a little girl and and I don't want
to be a little girl presumptuous. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry if
this upsets you because you're 19 or I'm sorry if this upsets
you because you're 22 or something, right? Or or if you're some
illegal guy or whatever, you know, when you're 19, you're a little
kid. Okay? Now, if you're 22, a 19-year-old is not a kid to you.
Okay? I'm 29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15year-old to me.
It's all the same, dude. Don't give me this just because of some
legal age of consent. What? >> I'm sorry. Like, dude, that
is entirely standalone. It has nothing to do with He's trying
to load context in there that doesn't exist that he explicitly
like filters off himself. He just lied blatantly there. Dead
to rights. He is not talking about he's talking about his own
he his own positions, his own thoughts on this. Okay. I'm sorry
if you're a 19 and you're 19-year-old and you don't think that
you're a kid, but you are a kid. Dude, that's insane that he
just tried to present that as if he's talking about like this
because they're he explicitly strips that context off when he
starts speaking. This loser, dude, just such a Hassan Hatam.
Okay,
what a weasly little liar, dude. What a weasly little liar, dude.
That's amazing, dude. Dude, what a weasly little liar. Dude,
>> but okay. I I guess you can pretend that that debate
was about me arguing that you should be able to [__]
19 and 15 year olds. Okay, >> it wasn't about that. It
was about you saying that a 19-year-old's a child in a similar
way that a 15-year-old will be a child to you, that they're not
developed, that they're kids have some legal age of consent,
whatever. >> Just because of some legal age of consent.
Huh? That's the age of consent. We I think we all agree that's
a good thing. Everyone but Destiny thinks that's good. We should
have a minimum age so that adults can't have sex with children.
Um, that is that is just an imagined line in the sand that I
will not conform to. Okay, he's he's
>> Okay, so this idea of me saying that the age of consent
is that's not at all what I'm saying there at all. Like it was
the exact opposite argument that just because this girl was 19
years old, the age of consent doesn't matter here. She was literally
mentally. That was the point. Um, I believe that quote comes
from this segment, right? But nope, no communication with the
parents. Get the girl pack up and leave. And now, now that you
have this perfect specimen, Z perfect specimen. Okay, I have
your girl with no family. >> Did he just perfectly skip
the section we watched? Did he just perfectly skip over the section
we watched? He perfectly So, we just watched the last like minute
of this clip, minute and a half of this clip from about 4530
till 47 minutes. He was watching the previous clip and now he
picks up at what was the time where he picked up at? 4530.
Oh, no. No. Hold on, hold on, hold on. He might watch through.
>> Okay. Who is a Okay, now you have this girl. What am
I going to do? I'm going to put baby in her. I'm going to put
a baby in her and now she's your slave forever. She has no friends,
which he didn't. She has no family because he's cutting her off
from them. She has nobody else that she can talk to. >> Oh,
he stops right before he stops right before. She has no job.
>> Wait, hold on. Maybe he doesn't stop right before. Maybe
he watches through the whole thing. And I'm actually wrong, >> right?
She has no real education, right? She's totally locked there
and she's his. That is disgusting. Okay. And that's kind of why
like the fact that he still defends this behavior is really irritating
to me because what he did was horrible. That kind of is literally
disgusting that he would try to trout a little girl and and I
don't want to be presumptuous. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. >> Oh,
he's going to play the whole thing. >> You're 19. >> I'm
Dude, you're 19. So, you're 19.
He's going to play it and he's just going to frame it. >> I'm
sorry if this upsets you because you're 22 or something, right?
Or if you're some legal guy or whatever, you know, when you're
19, you're a little kid. Okay. Now, if you're 22, a 19-year-old
is not a kid to you. Okay? I'm 29. A 19-year-old might as well
be a 15-year-old to me. It's all the [__] dude. Don't
give me this. Just because of some legal age of consent, whatever.
I have about as much in common with like an 18-year-old, 19-year-old
sophomore in high school. Any type of >> Where is the loading
here? I actually paused it too early.
Where's the >> me? It's all the same, dude. Yo, don't give
me this. Just because of some legal age of consent, whatever.
I have about as much in common with like an 18-year-old, 19-year-old
freshman in school as I would a sophomore in high school. Any
type of inclination towards any of those people is really weird.
Okay, now I know if you're 20 years old, it might bother you
to hear that. Like, no, I'm 19. I'm a real adult. Okay, I'm a
real adult. Okay, if your mom and dad, if you live with your
mom and dad, your mom and dad still pay all of your bills. You're
still a virgin. You've never been in a relationship. You don't
go to school. You've never even had a job before. You've never
lived on your own. You're a child. You're very much child. You
don't know what it's like to wake up and go into work to work
a job you hate because you have to pay a bill. Okay? You don't
know what it's like to have to make a decision between getting
kind of a cool car and a piece of car because you can't afford
it. You don't know what it's like. He's literally describing
exactly why his inclination towards Rose is describing.
I don't I don't I
Why Why is he playing this clip? Why is he Why is he playing
this clip? He's playing the All have to work an extra [__]
shift because you don't you don't have any life experience. You
don't know anything about anything. You're a child. Um so all
the people in chat like, "No, 19 years old. That's an adult.
That's an adult dog." No,
no. So I guess we can pretend that this was cut just to
I see. Oh, he's mixed up. I think he mixed up his own notes here.
So he was originally arguing that this was all about the kids
being re, right? And now he's arguing that actually I'm not arguing
that you should be able to [__] 15y olds, but we
never made that charge, right? We were just arguing that he was
he was laying out exactly why it's disturbing to have an attraction
to people who are either in high school or fresh out of high
school. Right? So he lays that out perfectly why it is that way.
Now he's doing this as a rebuttal to Ethan, but he's also maintaining
the previous part about how it's like, oh, this is all tinged
in. That part is not ting at all.
Jesus Christ, bro. Wait, I think I exited the video. >> Age
of consent. We >> um that I'm saying that like, oh no,
the age of consent. Let's minor again. Maybe Ethan's projecting
something on me there. Um and again, like >> I I don't
think there's any reason to argue that Ethan obviously got that
argument totally in the age of consent
>> I feel like I could give so many hot takes, but I can
never say them because >> Here's a hot take, but I would
defend it. That's the I'm not just saying hot takes, but say
takes. Here's one. I should defend it. Ready? Yep. >> 16
and 17y old people should be legal. Should be legal. >> I
got to go. I'll be back in a little >> If you're going
to hold people that are 16 years old forever accountable for
the dumb that they tweet, then you know what? They should have
all the other rights and every and responsibilities that come
along with being a adult. >> Talk about how actually it's
not but a >> Oh, that's a that would have been an important
one for for Ethan to have actually, wouldn't it?
I again, it's funny to cut the like 19year-old or whatever, but
like obviously there are some 19-year-olds that are more mature.
There are some 23 year olds that are less mature. Um, like I've
tried it with like uh there are 19-year-olds who are more mature.
Like the the like the 19-year-old who told me who I thought was
19 maybe maybe
who's actually 17 who I sent all of my private like uh relationship
meltdown DMs with Lawrence Southern to like that level of mature,
right? you know, 22 to 23 year olds who are still like going
to school and living with their parents and working on their
masters who like are fighting with their parents and those people
are a lot different than even somebody a couple years younger,
a 20-year-old who has lived on their own for a while. Uh, obviously
ages are proxies for life stages, life developments, and everything
else. Um, but I but yeah, I mean, if if if you want to fantasize
that I'm arguing against the age of consent, then go for >> I
think we all agree that's a good thing. Everyone but Destiny
thinks that's good. No, he's he's in that case, Desessie is clearly
arguing that like actually if you have any inclination towards
19-year-olds as a 30-year-old, you're probably a which is wild
given his future position of I'm going to actually meet and marry
this 19-year-old Molina. And then the girl who I can only say
I thought was 19, but possibly thought was younger, Rose, I'm
going to share all my private information, whole bunch of videos
with and you know, non-consensually
non-consensually delivered to her as well. Okay.
basically took ignored the women's who the women who are participating
their consent and send a bunch of to this girl I can at best
say was 19. >> We should have a minimum age so that adults
can't have with children that is that is just an imagined line
in the sand that I will not conform to. Okay. He's he's constantly
blurring the line and trying to normalize the act of >> like
is the is that is me saying that like the 19 and the 50-year-old
will have as much in common if they're in school having anything
that's blurring the line to what do you think I'm blurring the
>> just to be clear he said anybody with an inclination
towards either of those ages is suspect
>> line for for making an argument why you should date
or 15y olds or for saying why like even a 19-year-old is probably
than a 25-y old which direction you think the line is being blurred
here
like this is okay this isn't that bad this 15-year-old's hot
I want to this 15-year-old but I won't etc etc this is a pattern
long long pattern >> I have about as much in common with
like an 18year-old 19-year-old freshman in school as I would
a sophomore in high school any type of inclination towards >> how
did Ethan not realize that he's making the opposite argument
here.
How did he How did Ethan this up even? How do you watch these
clips back to back and this up? >> He's like freshman in
college, sophomore in high school. It's all good, baby.
>> I It's just It's This guy's
That Yeah. Okay. >> You blame the watching Nicholas Fat
Oreo stream. Maybe he would actually have some actual context
of what this conversation is about. >> Nicholas fat Oreo.
Did I have fat Oreo or like eats Oreos on here? I do. I do. But
it's it's terrible nicknames for ops.
Terrible nicknames for ops. Top right corner. That's Dude, if
we get ironic Palestinian support, we're we're going gang busters.
We're we're we got a bingo. Okay. But you know what? Listen,
I love the clip champion. Do it more. I love it. Okay. >> Those
bikini pics in the DMs. >> Those people is really weird.
Okay. Now, I know if you're 20 years old, it might bother you
to hear that like, "No, I'm 19. I'm a real adult." Okay, I'm
>> And then there's one more clip I want to show you guys.
>> Okay, can't play the rest of that. I got to move to
the next thing. Okay. >> Of when we were talking about
Vosch and the Loi horse controversy and he accidentally opened
a folder and he had lolly and horse on his computer and everybody
was clowning on him except one person. There was one person that
came to his defense. >> Oh, this is rough, too.
>> Why? Well, this this take was so bizarre. I remember
at the time being absolutely struck by it and I pulled this straight
from my memory because it was just so just so shocking to me.
But here here's his take on on lollycon which is the
>> Ethan's like Ethan's way of um going after people is
so stupid.
>> Oh, hold on. Reuben >> Ruben Ruben donated.
>> Didn't Destiny used to play a game called Fat Oreo?
>> Okay, thank you very much. Reuben Jesus Christ.
Um,
so hold on. A few minutes ago, did he bring up mature 19-year-olds
and then say they were working on their masters or was that immature
24 year olds? I think it was immature 24 year olds. But in any
case, okay, in any case, haha, Reuben, Ruben, Ethan's way of
handling this and doing analysis is I'm going to get clips everybody
else agrees are bad, and then I'm going to go, "Isn't that bad?
Isn't that bad,
guys? Isn't that bad? Oh my god, how bad is that? That's so bad.
Isn't that bad? That's like his way of doing like a hit piece
basically. Isn't that bad? Isn't that so bad? Isn't that so bad?
It's like, dude, you could you do a little more work than that.
Could you just do a little bit more? Like, say why this is bad.
Don't just play this clip and go, "This really struck me."
Say why it's bad at least make a normalization argument, right?
But he's just going to go, "Look at how gross this guy is. Didn't
you know Vos was bad and Destiny defended him for the bad thing?
Oh my god." hentai drawings involving children. Did >> you
see the lolly discussion on Reddit? You know, if Vaj was a better
person and not just a piece of I'd be in the trenches cuz you
know what? Who the [__] cares about lolli? Who cares
about drawing? Imagine your life is so boring you give a [__]
about animated cartoon >> Imagine your life's so boring
that you care about children. Imagine being so bored in your
life that you actually care if grown-ups want to minor. Like
>> yeah, like Ethan just gets soy about it that it's like,
well, like you can you can make a normalization argument, but
you're arguing he doesn't care about people want to [__]
kids. And you could easily say, well, I think Lolly doesn't make
kid people [__] kids. Or you could there's a whole
bunch of opinions you could have there, right? But Ethan just
is like going so overboard that he's just the perfect foil for
Destiny. He's just like super about it. >> We're That's
not what we're talking about right now. What? Again, I know that
he loves to make everything about cuz Ethan has a rich history
with obsessively making jokes and everything else, but nobody
on my stream, we do not normalize minors. I've never normalized
minors. I've never in my entire life argued for a lower age of
consent that 16 and 17y old people should be legal. Should be
legal. >> I got to go. I'll be back in a little >> If
you're going to hold people that are 16 years old forever accountable
for the dumb that they tweet, >> then you know what? of
all the other rights and every responsibilities that come along
with being a adult. >> Now, I'm sure he's going to argue
that he is uh he's saying, "Well, we shouldn't cancel kids for
their tweets when they're below age."
>> But that is actually just an argument for lowering the
age of consent right there. So, this has just never ever happened
on my stream. He is projecting so much weird onto me. And by
projecting, I mean just reading it straight from threads or from
Nicholas Guru or anything else. But
>> straight from threads, is that reading down my Kiwi
farms? He's just reading down my Kiwi Farms thread. They're just
reading down my Kiwi Farms thread. I'm going to add it. I'm I'm
taking it. I'm taking it. That's reading down my Kiwi Farms thread.
Reading down a thread.
>> I don't know. I I don't know if it's that minor of a
detail. >> Like, how old is the girl? I don't know. How
old is the drawing? >> I don't think I have that. Sorry,
not [__] up. Okay, people are like calling the FBI
on vouch. He's looking at cartoons that I don't like. I think
that like bro, >> that's not the criticism. It's not that
they don't like it. Uh, it might have a fine plot and the plot
might be a banger. I don't know. The problem of course is that
it's depicting children being by adults. That's just, you know,
that's a detail that's >> come jokes a free space by the
way to >> Okay. Now, I'm not here to judge anybody on what
kind of animated they decide to collect or show to other people
>> album right now. Um, >> this is uh Rick and Morty.
>> No way. That's on That's Rick and Morty. >> Yeah.
This is from an episode of Rick and Morty where Mr. Mees runs
train on
>> Mr. Mees and all of his buddies run train on uh April.
>> He's not I can see
>> good observation
thoughts on this. >> Oh my god.
>> He meant summer, not April. >> Describe what you're
seeing. >> Oh my god. >> Describe this for the people
who can't see it. >> It looks like a wolf >> here
into the mic. >> Oh my god. >> Go ahead. Describe
that. Go ahead. Uh, >> I will say I did do the research.
It's uh, it's summer. Uhoh. Uhoh. This is why you don't soy about
this stuff, right? This is why you don't soy about this stuff.
It's why you just do something simple like, "Hey, um, I got to
reevaluate evaluate your jokes when I find out you minor and
find out that you might have kept all this, right?" It's why
you do that.
It's It's why you do that. It's why you say, "Oh, I maybe see
your jokes in a slightly different light." Because when you when
you performatively virtue signal all the time, obviously you're
on the internet, you've done edgy stuff. You're probably going
to run into problems. Oh, we just got Ethan's parents. We've
uh we've opened up a new line of win. Okay. A new line of winning.
How how the [__] do you even say that? How do you
even say that? Okay, let's go. And Summer is only 17 years old.
Okay, so he is now. Okay. Do I guys? I think we're just two more
instances of Ethan hypocrisy away from it being totally okay
and legal for Destiny to retain multiple child videos and to
try to fly a minor out to him to another state. Okay? Like if
Ethan's a hypocrite two more times, Destiny gets off scotfree.
The FBI by law has to let him go. Okay? Just two more. Two more
times Ethan Klein's hypocritical and Destiny gets off on all
charges. It's
We cannot survive any more Ethan
All right. It's >> actually think he's getting off to Lcon
or that he enjoys this despite that creepy smile he has while
sharing his
hentai with his parents. Probably not. But like is this is this
if this is the standard we're going to use. I mean Jesus Christ.
You know, I only said I didn't give a [__] about
it. You're over here literally showing it to your mom and dad
on stream. What the [__] They were talking about
like Elsa and other Disney hentai earlier, but I'm too easy to
look up the ages as well. those girls. He calling this guy his
way to do some [__] preschoolers. Okay, until then.
Get out of here. Who cares? And then he sets this bar. He goes,
I only care preschoolers, which is three-year-olds, bro. Just
want to see his reaction to the Willy Mac video. I would just
love for I would love if Ethan Ethan gets to like the actual
talking points near the end of this. And I don't know if Ethan
actually like, man, I don't know if Destiny's actually going
to react to it. Desty's probably going to go look at all this
Ethan hypocrisy and shut the off. Shut it the off. He's just
going to get out. >> Oh, threeyear-olds, kindergarten go,
baby. first, second, third, fifth grade, basically an adult.
>> Where do we draw? Okay, so three-year-old is not okay
or that's when it's When do we actually draw the >> What
is the >> on and when she was legal, she was adult, but
she's clearly saying she was uncomfortable, didn't want it. He's
44.
That's a That's a That to me should be a pedophile cuz that's
a child. You're a grown ass man. Yes, it's not legally a pedophile,
but it's so >> people misuse the word some of the like
>> This is unfortunately Ethan Klein's DJer phase. Okay,
Ethan was a big Destiny fan. He realized that when he made these
arguments in public, he looked really weird to all of the people
around him and he had to give it up. Okay. Coincidentally became
a much more attractive human being when after giving it up. Very
shocking. Very very confusing. Very shocking. But um [__]
like a 8-year-old. >> Oh,
8 years old, not 3 years old. My bad. It's not preschool. It's
uh what is that? Second grade. Yeah, I guess. My bad, Ethan.
You know, you got me there, I guess.
>> And honestly, this is just a few many many clips of
him children and just being a total deviant, right? So, >> a
few of many, many, many clips. So, first of all, I pretty half
of these didn't even involve like me and Rose is not a minor.
Okay. Um,
the other clip is here is me saying I'm not 15-year-old. You
don't minor. Uh, you've got like a crazy troll story from JTV.
None of this about soliciting.
>> Oh, hold on. We actually have to go through this list
as he talks. Okay. The other clip is here is me saying, "I'm
not 15y old. Be careful. You don't
>> That's not him saying be careful. Don't not to miners.
saying, "These miners are almost so hot that I I want to [__]
them so badly that I'm willing to look the other way on the law."
And he's bragging about how hot the minor is. Okay, that's not
him going PSA guys, don't [__] minor. It's him going,
"This minor is so hot I'm almost willing to look the other way
on the law." Okay, look at this picture of her in a bikini, guys.
You see what I'm saying? You see what I'm saying? Wait, what
the rewind? Rewind. What? He met Moses. Wait, what did he >> Many
clips of him children and just being a total deviant, right?
So, >> a few of many, many, many clips. So, first of all,
I pretty half of these didn't even like Mia Rose is not a minor.
Okay. Um,
>> yeah, Mia Rose is not a minor. >> The other clip
is here is me saying I'm not 15-year-old.
>> So, totally lies about the second part. >> Minors.
Uh, you got like a crazy troll story from JTV. None of this is
about
>> The thing about the 8-year-old shaking their receiving
pictures like the fact that he now he's like built this extensive
case. Uh, one is me talking about uh a 19-y old 14-y old maybe
isn't considered like all of these exact same type 19year-old
to 14y old maybe isn't
um that would be like a normalizing thing. That's what the argument
would be there. Normalizing Ethan didn't uh Ethan didn't make
sure that he could make his strongest, you know, accusation with
the amount of evidence he had. And he looks kind of silly now
because he's going to ar he's arguing that Destiny is trying
to normalize kids or trying to [__] kids. And I don't
think he's got the evidence here to to say you could maybe go
in the normalizing direction with all the jokes. I think there's
way better ways to make the arguments here, right? The argument
is is like, okay,
let me ask you, Destiny, how many people called the cops on Ethan
because of his jokes? Like, are we We don't really have a problem
with jokes. We kind of have a problem with the jokes once now
you've you sort of like laid all the jokes out and now actually
we find out that you were minor, right? You say you didn't know
her age, but then you retained a bunch of her after finding out
her age, right? And now that looks weird. Like if you if you
get actual credible like charges
like you are you understand that all those jokes get totally
rewritten that that changes our priors on everything you've ever
done. That's that's the real problem here. And that's what Ethan
should have stuck to was asking questions about Rose, asking
questions about this. And instead he got way off base. He tried
to like re he tried to watch like twothirds of the Ryan Beard
video without understanding it and thought he could cook and
he can't cook at all. So all of his stuff that's going away from
Rose is mostly right. I But again, I think I said after we watched
the Ethan thing like, "Hey, you really [__] that
up. Hopefully you don't [__] Rose stuff up." And
I'd like to see Desi's response to that stuff. >> Keep
going. And I would argue probably a bit worse. I've been told
by Ethan. I don't understand why he's the one who would come
at me for jokes like this. And I am going to the full snark thread.
If that's what we're doing, then it
>> she spread her sexy little body all over the, you know,
prison yard. >> I've seen this 20 times. >> Million
times. >> A lot of times when you weren't here. >> Oh
god, that's another Ethan hypocrisy. Destiny's one Ethan hypocrisy
away from them giving him a total exemption for retaining child.
Okay. Nobody will care that he retained child at all if we could
just find one more Ethan hypocrisy. It didn't even play like
in the whole champ argument. I'm not making an argument for a
lower age. Me and Rose was not a minor. Um like none of these
like in the 15-year-old bikini pic the whole thing is literally
don't [__] minors. That was the whole point in talking
to my uh teammates like it's just crazy that
it was not that was not dude that lie is crazy that that was
his point was don't [__] minors. That was not the
point of that clip. He just keeps lying about it. >> This
strong huge like ground of okay now that we know for sure you
have this massive problematic history because this collection
of like egg clips from 13 to 16 years ago. Seriously, when I
was like younger than half the girls you're talking about in
your lips. What the >> With that important backstory, now
let's go to the parts that I got wrong that I'm going to issue
a heartfelt apology for. And this goes out almost a sincere.
His point was don't fall for jailbait. That was not his point.
That was not his point. Or else he would have said don't fall
for jailbait.
His point was look how hot this jailbait is. Holy [__]
I'm I'm right there. I'm right. I might I might say it. I might
say it. That was his point. >> Apology to Destiny for absolutely
getting this wrong. Now, here's what happened. This conversation
here, he says, "Uh, Ti, send me the feed pics. This is from a
different girl. It's from Instagram. He never spoke to us on
Instagram." She points out correctly, as far as we know. So,
this was with another girl he claims was 26. Okay, fine. I'll
take it for her. And then this one also he claims was with the
same girl. And this is the one that says, "She said, "My parents
are like super super strict. Don't do this. Don't do that. Don't
go there. Don't talk to him." And he said, "Well, it would be
so hot to drive you home from a date and make you suck me off
in the car. I'd love to send you inside your parents after making
you swallow a full load for me." So, apologies. Um, uh, you know,
that was not to Rose. This was to some other lucky lady. But
but this one Okay, to reiterate the only Oh, hold on. Hold on.
We're getting uh Dude, this is just so awesome. This is just
This is absolutely epic. Okay, we've got everything's melting
down. Got Destiny tweeting. Apparently, Ethan is still IG storying
about me. Blah blah blah blah blah. I don't even know what this
is. We'll get to it in a little bit. But Odar in the replies
to do we call CPS?
Do we do we call CP standing back and standing by? Ethan Klein's
about to realize that the number one community in terms of harassment,
you haven't met them, okay? They're not sers. They're not 30-year-old
women. They're the 28 to 37year-old
compai immigrants, okay? They're coming for you. They're coming
for you. They're coming for you now, Ethan. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Only reason why any of my [__] is even being
talked about right now isn't because some victim has come forward
and claimed something or isn't any of that [__] It's
because some guy leaked a [__] ton of mic material
online a year ago. these DMs that he's reading right now are
from some other [__] uh chick who I think was an
Andrew Tan also leaking my DMs. Why the [__] are
you reading through leaked explicit material on stream just to
like have a goof at me? Like if some girl had
>> Hold on. How many times How many times has he leaked
explicit material? I'm just curious. >> This was some other
lucky lady. >> I got to listen to this virtue signal >> Okay.
Oh, Dan's pretending still. Dan's pretending still. He doesn't
want to come out and say Ethan's gotten totally duped. Ethan,
you trusted me? All right. This should be the Trojan horse comic.
I think this same artist did a Trojan horse comic. Okay, e now
I understand why Dan did the rust thing. Okay,
I get it. I get it. Dan's Dan's pretending to not be involved.
Okay, to reiterate, the only reason why any of my is even being
talked about right now isn't because some victim has come forward
and claimed something or isn't any of that because some guy leaked
a of my explicit material online a year ago. These DMs that he's
reading right now are from some other chick. I think it was an
Anderson fan also leaked my DMs. Why the are you reading through
leaked explicit material on stream just to like have a goof at
me? Like like you did with Lauren de Lagona, like you did with
Denims, like you did with like h
how many people have you not he's done this so many times. I
have no idea how he could possibly virtue signal about this.
He's been in his opinion like the re he calls this reading my
revenge by the way. How many times has he been the revenge in
that situation where he explicitly because somebody's pissed
him off decides to leak with them? To be fair, the denim's leak
was fair game. No, I don't believe I don't believe uh revenge
is a like turnabout thing. I don't think that's you're allowed.
I don't think somebody's allowed to go I find you disgusting.
I'd never you're like, "Oh, yeah. Well, I have a video of us
that I get to post on the internet now cuz you said you would
never me, stupid bitch."
That's not how life works. That's not how anything works. If
you think that's how it works, please just don't interact with
the real world. You are going to go to prison.
Did he leak denims? No. Kogan style. What he does is he refers
to you reading his his leaked on the internet as reading his
revenge. He did it yesterday or the day before, I forget, right?
That the Denims leak was just a combo. No, he also leaked
text with her as well. He did leak a thing that was illegally
recorded with denims, though. Proof of a crime. He did do that.
If some girl had her explicit messages leaked, would you be doing
the same thing with your whole feminist crew here? Like, oh,
let me like read this girl's explicit DMs.
In fact, I believe that he actually did do that. Did Ethan not
literally use the that Destiny leaked about Denims against Denims
in his like story? Didn't he explicitly use that and say, "I
heard you were trying to suck Destiny's dick." Has Ethan not
explicitly done that with quote unquote revenge is what Destiny
refers to it as
against Destiny's victim in that situation? Bro, the people here
are so
in like a in a synergistic way that this is becoming some of
the most ironically funny I've ever watched on the internet.
Like, holy [__]
Are you serious? Listen to that again. >> On stream just
to like have a goof at me. Like, you're listening to my You're
reading off my leaked material on stream to have a goof. >> These
DMs that he's reading right now are from some other Jake. I think
it's Andrew Tan also leaking my DMs. Why the are you reading
through? That's a bingo, by the way. Leaked explicit material
on stream just to like have a goof at me. Like, if some girl
had her explicit messages leaked, would you be doing the same
thing with your whole feminist crew here? Like, oh, let me like
read this girl's explicit DMs. Um, also, this again, this chick
was like So, I don't know if he read the the Denim's DMs on stream.
Okay. But he absolutely talked about them. Uh, hold on. Somebody
could find this. I'm I'm not going to go find it in the background.
We can keep reacting to this, but if somebody wants to find it,
there is absolutely an instance of of Ethan Klein talking about
how Denims wanted to Destiny to get on top referred to those
leaks, right? I'm almost positive. >> Let's go. Let's try
to find it. When I started talking to some British all of these
weird things that he grabs on to of like, oh my god, like Des
mentioned this person's like braces or Destiny mentioned that
this person like live with their parents. Not everybody moves
out of their parents home at 18. I'm pretty sure that girl was
visiting her parents. So, it's not like she was still living
there. And it's like I literally have Invisalign right now that
>> and the Rose situation. What about her?
Surely that surely she wasn't a minor, right? That girl who she
was she was 26 and she lived with her parents. Rose. Oh. Uh I
have braces now, guys. I have Invisalign now. Finish. These are
not like child things. If you wanted to point to like dating,
you could go back to the photo shoot that you guys did with the
one girl. You could look at people like Belia you've done like
two hour suck with when you do when you invite them to your podcast.
Um it's just like it's humiliating. It's disgusting. It's like
weird. um that you want to like dig through like all this random
and then like have a goof and a laugh and everything else. Um
I don't know. I just I don't know how you could possibly claim
to have any sort of like moral high ground here when you're literally
just reading off like leaks material of mine to have a goof on
stream after playing down, you know, like Ryan Beard's video
for how horrible of a person I am.
>> Playing down Ryan's Ryan Beard's video. He used like
two clips from Ryan Beard's video and totally [__]
the whole narrative of it.
>> The Okay, so now that he's done all of his poisoning
the well. Okay. Okay, now that he's laid down everything that
he needs to. So, now he spends time going through this rose person
who supposedly Kiwi Farms has dug up stuff about. Um, I haven't
been able to. No way. No way. He doesn't respond to this, right?
Come on. No way. He just skips out on the only relevant part
of the video.
No shot. No shot.
Come on, man. Going through this rose person who supposedly DB
Farms has dug up stuff about. Um,
just to be clear, uh, former Willie M, former Destiny sweeper
Willy Mack and Tur, not Turkey Tom, but Tom Foolery both agree
on this one that Rose is 100% a minor. Okay. People who were
on Destiny's side. Destiny used to have people who would take
his side on things. Okay. Is this the one? Nope, it's not this
one. It's uh it's a it's uh this one. Tom has showed me 100%
proof that Rose is underage. I don't really. Now,
do we take the combined deductive powers of Tom and Willie Mack
and give them a lot of credence? No, we don't. We don't. But
I'm just saying those are the people that Destiny's community
would give credence to, right? We think they're we've luckily
verified it on our end, too, okay, with people who can actually
do research, who can actually read. We've had some of the literate
people here who can read, go over it, and and figure out that
yes, she was under 18. Okay. Willy's exasperated tweet about
Destiny skipping their DMs makes you really makes really makes
you realize how Willie is.
Oh, I didn't see that.
Hold on.
Yo, guys, responding with 120k live viewers. Did he really skip
our entire DMs?
Yeah, he he would do that. Yeah, he would do that. Uh, this was
my favorite one. Okay. People defending Destiny for holding on
to CP have gone from that's just a Kiwi Farms talking point.
We don't know if it's true to it's legal because of the civil
court case. I have not found one lawyer agreeing with that. To
Ethan's dad was 21 and did his mom when she was 16, so it's fine.
To 17 isn't a child, so having on your computer is fine. His
Reddit is filled with all this trash and more. Yeah, it's been
like that. It been like that, bro. It been like that for a long
time. Willie Mac finally waking up.
My god. You see this log? I have not seen any of the logs yet,
Shimsky. But I did want to show with this one. Hold on. There's
a mantis tweet that goes with this. Okay, there's a mantis tweet
that goes with it. He's not wrong. Just be honest and say you
don't give a [__] in this case. It's not that hard.
Sorry. The Mantis tweets are funny. Somebody keeps updating me
on the Mantis tweets. Okay. Mantis tweets are on point. It's
the kilo tweet. Hold on. The kilo tweet. The kilo tweet. Destiny
is actually Yes. Yes. We've read the kilo tweet. Never mind.
I've read the kilo tweet before. It's a good one. Do you see
this log overload? I remove Willie because he's
I'm pretty sure Oh, I removed Willie because he's I'm pretty
sure Tom is just looking at the that same ticket. I have no way
to verify if that thing is actually real or not though because
it seems like it's only accessible to people who have access
to some backend non-publicf facing database. Nope. I'm pretty
sure anybody can sign up for this. But beyond that, we actually
have multiple points of validation now beyond that. So Destiny's
just not looking into it cuz he doesn't he doesn't want to know,
right? Destiny doesn't want to know. Rose, anything has Erdite
said anything about the Rose Pedal controversy or is Mantis the
only woman online willing to defend this right now? Uh I think
Mantis the only one. when you start your tour of content uh content
creators or sorry your tour where all you ask of other content
creators is a simple JOC was right admission.
Oh, I don't care about that. Uh this is not I don't know if like
oh I was right. I realize some people have said that like a lot
of the stuff that I am correct about hasn't even the other shoe
hasn't dropped on it yet. Right. Like like I think dude especially
if potentially criminal is correct in in like some of the civil
case stuff. Okay, that's going to be rough. And like we're just
correct that like Desi is a piece of this. If you needed this
to get proof that Desi's a piece of [__] then I don't
know what to tell you. Chill alert. What do you mean shill alert?
Guys, if you like the content, pay money. Pay money. Pay money.
Pay money.
What is this? >> I just read a quote that said, "The reason
why men mistake kindness and politeness is flirting is because
they would never be kind or polite to someone >> This isn't
a actually responding.
I don't care. Why link me clips? Thank you for wasting my time.
>> I haven't been able to verify the authenticity. Nobody
close to me has been able to verify the authenticity in so far
as uh there are things concerned with my court case. The thing
that's annoying about him running through all of this stuff now
is that and Ethan knows this. Okay, there's two huge things.
Sorry, I get it. Aerodite's funny, but like I don't want to watch
random air clips when I'm watching something actually consequential.
>> One, I am actively involved in a huge civil litigation
case that is directly involving these conversations for you to
Okay.
No.
You can talk about the you're retaining. You can talk about a
whole bunch of stuff.
Uh all basically all of your conversations with Rose. The things
that are relevant to Pixie's case are places where you violated
Pixie privacy.
>> Will the haters be when this drama blows over and people
still prefer Destiny to them? Not even CP can do it. >> Thank
you for tweeting the Mantis tweet at me. Exactly.
Uh, Creger, don't don't time Riyle out for a week for telling
you to comp yourself, okay? In a video game, he disavows. I get
that he's not a fan of Arerite and you're not a fan of him, but
we're just going to play nice for now, okay? We're all going
to play nice. It's fine. It's fine. We're all fine. Okay. Okay.
Uh, Ry, that's your one get out of jail free card. Don't talk
to the people with hammers that way if you want to stay in the
chat. Okay. Only only chance. Only chance you get literally zero
more chances.
Okay. in a huge civil litigation case that so Destiny is trying
to use the civil litigation case. Okay, I believe that is a square.
Are we going to use civil litigation to excuse why we won't comment
on something?
Hold on. Hold on. It's got to be here somewhere, right? Oh, do
I not have a square for that? Oh, I thought he was going to say
lawsuits prevent me from commenting. Oh, that's rough. Oh, I
can't speak on this due to the court case. There it is right
there.
Can't speak on this due to the court case. Okay, see Sam not
involved in your court case can't even be presented as evidence.
Your progression of relationship with Rose, right? And how you
validated her age has nothing to do. Hasn't he been hasn't he
been very clear that so many of the other facts so many of the
other people who had their their
sent non-consensually are irrelevant to this case? Why would
how he met Rose or why would Rose's age actually pertain to the
facts of this case? Why would that matter? I actually have no
idea.
It's this. Okay, there's two huge things. one, I am actively
involved in a huge civilation case that is directly involving
these conversations for you to take after doing this whole bit
of taking random clips from some other video to take that and
then to use that as a platform to then demand right just like
you said team to demand that I come up and try to explain every
single thing that's not even being alleged by any hypothetical
victim but just been dug up and leaked by other people right
that >> why would it have to be alleged by the victim wait
if I talked to you about like
what if the victim was uh what if the victim had passed away,
right? Would that make them any less of a minor? Would that make
you any less in possession of their Would that make that any
less illegal?
Why does a victim have to be alive and and accusing you of things
for for you to get in trouble for it? I don't understand why
that would be the case. I'm pretty sure you can't I'm pretty
sure you can't video.
This can't be a possible thing. Okay, you record child with a
victim. Okay, then you kill them and it's no longer child. You're
only on the on the hook for the murder. Is that Is that where
we're at with Destiny now? Guys, there's no victim. Nobody's
actually claiming this is a problem. I'm pretty sure the state
says it's a problem, right? This has to be katharsis for you
seeing everyone calling this POS out. Not really. Sorry. Uh he
was a total piece of [__] before and it was very
obvious. He Nothing about this person the content of this person's
character is even one iota different knowing the difference between
Rose's age then and now.
His cont the content of his character is precisely the same that
it took this for people to see it is honestly a little blackpilling
more than it is like cathartic or helpful or anything like that.
If it doesn't involve the victim, you're also now blasting all
of their to the ends of the earth for who the knows what reason,
right? >> Oh, I Oh no, I don't have this in there. [__]
I wanted to put in performative virtue signal over something
you clearly don't care about. Guys, I can't believe you're blasting
this to all over the public. This like victim. If they're really
a minor, they're a victim and you're blasting us all. Brother,
you went to your DG chat and taunted your KF thread and provided
unique only in your possession personally identifiable information
so they could dox her. How in the world are you now virtue signaling
as if you care about her privacy? That is insane. How his ability
to do this is out of this world to me, right? That like, oh,
you guys like don't care about her privacy at all.
brother, you can't make that allegation. You are the one who
made her famous in every single thing that's not even being alleged
by any hypothetical victim, but just been dug up and leaked by
other people, right? That if it does involve the victim, you're
also now blasting all of their to the ends of the earth for who
the knows what reason, right? That I'm supposed to come on and
try to proactively defend against all of this while I've had
the FBI while I've been swatted twice once with my son here before.
Um, well, I again in an active civil litigation suit where every
single [__] thing I say about it has the defendant
or not the defendant, the plaintiff throwing it into court filings
at me to waste.
>> He's a victim, guys. He's the eternal victim. Sorry,
I got to finish eating before I talk more. More of my money and
more of my time. I've got like eight fully briefed motions before
a judge right now that we're waiting for adjudication on is insane
to me. There is no world for all of his like wellah for all of
this talk that you would expect me to ever be able to come out
and give any type of substantiated spon response to some that
doesn't even involve a person that's actually making a claim.
This is just that is being posted and leaked on Kiwi Farms about
me. There's not even a person out here. I'm like the only person
in the history of the internet who's people trying to cancel
based on no [__] person making any claims against
me. I just don't see how this could possibly be true. His his
thing is that by the way um Rose could very easily unless she
has some really tangible allegation that she was trafficked that
she was forced or blackmailed into doing this she has sold
right there's every reason for her not to want to make herself
public to even make a statement on this to let herself be seen
in any way Destiny was the person who put her out there to be
publicly viewed right
and she's probably not gonna come out and make an allegation
until she is like actually served with noticed or arrested or
something along these lines, right? She has every reason to stay
hidden. That doesn't make your retaining of child better. Destiny.
It doesn't change anything there.
Didn't solo technically. Yeah. So, he's going to do the thing.
He thinks he can do the thing where like, oh, well, the victim
of it hasn't accused me. So, because this was like um with his
grinder thing, this is what he did, right? You can't accuse me.
If the victim isn't accusing me, you can't accuse me. And he
tried to do it. Uh yeah, it it's like it's a very it doesn't
work here. It just doesn't work. It doesn't work. >> It's
just like an outlandishly insane um it's an insane [__]
situation to be in. Um I So, and I >> and realistically,
he accused him, right? He's the one who told Willy Mack about
this. He's the one who accused himself. He's the one who made
the group chat to find the person. He's the one who shared stills
from the video in that group chat.
Allegedly. Allegedly. I also have to be careful because obviously
everybody records every single [__] thing I say and
every sing has been said to the FIB a million times which let
me be ultra clear. Okay, let me be clear on a few things. Okay,
one, I do not have any of the material that these guys think
CM whatever the else on my computer. Okay, number one.
I told you on my computer. On my computer. On my computer. Right.
Did I not tell you that's exactly how that was going to go? That
he is going to do this little this little signal around. He's
going to make it very clear that he has it on some hard drive
he's retaining, right? But he's going to make the differentiation
of like on my computer right now cuz that was what Willy's allegation
was cuz Willy's a right. He's he's explicitly said it's in his
possession. He has explicitly said he made copies of everything.
So where did he get the VLC screenshot from? Almost certainly
from that same group chat,
right? Almost certainly from that same group chat that he was
using to try to find Rose. Like he would have taken that screenshot
probably in December, I'm guessing, and been sending that to
people to try to help find things. trying to find things. That's
likely where it came from. >> One. Number two. All right.
I didn't send any of this. There was no child stuff like that
ever. Said the [__] Willy Mack. Okay. Number two.
It's not like he censored anything or anything like that. Okay.
Number three. If you want to interpret my messages in the worst
way possible. >> [__] Sorry. I looked away
for number >> Okay. Number one. Number. All right. I didn't
send any of this. There was no child stuff like that ever. Sent
to Willy Mac. Okay. Number two. It's not like he >> sent
to Willy Mac. sent to Willy Mack. I didn't send anything like
this to Willie Mack. Okay. Uh, are we gonna pretend that he's
not aware that we all think that he sent a bunch of this in that
group chat? That that email is real, that the email in Twitter
DMs are real? I told you the things he doesn't say are going
to be the most informative here. And that's obviously playing
itself out, right? He is very, very specific in his language.
He censored anything or anything like that. Okay. Number three,
if you want to interpret my messages in the worst way possible
and you want to and that's going to be the basis for some FBI
call, listen, I don't give a if you think that it's illegal and
you've called the FBI, I don't even care that Willie Beck did
that. Okay? In in I think that arguably you could even say like,
"Oh, sure." Like maybe uh maybe it's a responsibility to do whatever.
That's totally fine. If you think that I'm paying $95,000 a month
to my current law firm to ignore every single thing that they're
telling me about everything that's related to this case, you
>> Nobody said that. We said you probably did a little
oopsie and didn't tell them one very specific part or you did
it in a way that was conditional and let them maintain deniability
and they gave you like some some coke strategy. But I guarantee
if he said yeah solo told me in November 2024 that she was a
minor can I keep this? They would have said no, right? So he
just said he's paying 95k to his lawyers is what he said.
in I think that arguably you could even say like, "Oh, sure."
Like maybe uh maybe it's a responsible thing to do whatever.
That's totally fine. If you think that I'm paying $95,000 a month
to my current law firm to ignore every single thing that they're
telling me about everything that's related to this case, you
are cooked and you're more
So apparently what what are we 7 months into the lawsuit?
$700,000 into the lawsuit. $95,000 a month.
We got to be at least 500k into the lawsuit, right? I I love
that he is concerned about this here, but he won't stop violating
the actual like the judge's actual orders. All he'd have to do
to stop stop having to respond to a ton of different motions
is stop being a on the internet. It's like he wants to pay Andrew
Breler as much as he possibly can. Uh let's see here.
95K month while toying with KF. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
H okay. But the thing he says here, yeah, this is uh this is
the way he responds to things to ignore everything they say.
No, we don't think you ignored everything they say. We think
you like probably left out one tiny little piece and that was
that ends up being really big. Or uh Andrew Breler basically
advised you to keep child in your possession pending a civil
case.
videos
that you had reason to believe were Andrew Breler told you to
keep those on your computer or in some on some device that you
have access to, right? That's your That's what you're
That's what he's explicitly saying now, right? Is Andrew Breler
counseledled him that in spite of the clear possibility that
this is you keep this on a device on a hard drive that you retain
control of. And uh yeah, if you want to blast out a couple screenshots
from that stuff, go ahead. Go ahead. and the writeups that Pisco
was blasting about the three litigants that you are uh that you
have lawsuits against Casey Tron Frogan and everybody else. Okay.
All right. The um Oh, the if if you want to do all this, you
want to report whatever, fine. I don't care. People call the
FBI all the time anyway. If you think you're doing some novel
thing, go for it. But the fact that you would then publish a
video on it, um again, I don't want to dive into the Okay, this
one is going to unfortunately be right on the money. And I understand
I know exactly where he's going with this cuz people people don't
want to seem like they're way too against Willie Mack, right?
I talked to some people about this who who've given Willie Mack
a lot of like ah it seems kind of unhinged to say this but I'm
going to say it. Okay, you're a complete subhuman [__]
If you think that going to the cops about some CP thing is and
you're you're doing it like legitimately and within a day you
publish a video to the internet on that, you are the highest
tier of inbred
up. Okay, obviously you are only doing that to virt to to like
basically get clout for yourself. That's the only [__]
thing you're doing. It's incredibly [__] obvious.
Like it's all about internet wars to you. It is 0% about doing
the right thing. And you just prove that out with your conduct.
But we already knew that. Listen again, if you took this if you
needed this from Willy Mack, this coming out from Willy Mack
to realize he is a subhuman
[__] Okay? Okay, if it took that for you, if it took
this video for you to realize that, then I don't know what to
tell you. Okay, you're not paying attention. Andreas, but you
must understand that by doing that, you are literally undermining
every single thing that you're attempting to do. What? Like,
why the would you publish a video on that? You must understand
how be beyond stupid that is. If everything that you were alleging
was true, how would that be? Why would you do that? Why would
you ever do this? This is so stupid. So the idea that there's
like any concern or care here for anybody or that that you're
trying to do the right thing is completely undermined and completely
and totally obliterated on on all of this. It's literally just
farming for content for farming engagement um to try to get me
I guess swatted again or whatever the [__] else.
Like it's so
uh no I think I do think like listen as much as the video publishing
is performative I do think that they want you to go down if you
had child on your computer if you had child some hard drive that
you were saving. I don't think they like want you to get I just
think they value clout way more than they value you getting caught,
but I think they It's not like they don't value you getting caught
or you caring.
Yeah. Also,
if people call the FBI on you because you've made it clear through
DMs to people on the internet, through big content creators who
do exposees, right, that you probably are retaining copies of
child. That's not really swatting anymore, is it? SWAT, by the
way, is when you call and make it clear that there's an emergency
that a SWAT team would be required for. SWAT is not reporting
crimes. That is not what SWAT is. Let's all stop being [__]
That's not Let's all stop being at like, you know, operating
at Willie Max intellectual level and raise it up a little bit
and realize that SWAT is when you try to create the appearance
of an emergency that requires a SWAT team. So, they will break
in and anybody who's like a valid who who like moves fast. You're
trying to create that environment. If you just say, "I think
this guy's got child on his computer." That is not a swatting.
Okay? That's not swatting. If you say, "Hey, I think these people
are like partying and you need to go them." That's not swatting.
That's like, "Oh, you're going you're doing a noise complaint,
right?" A false noise noise complaint is not swatting. Reporting
somebody for what you believe is child in their possession is
not swatting.
Trying to get a SWAT team to their house that will them is swatting.
Just to be clear, insane to me. Yeah. I can't like listen maybe
once my case is over if you want I'll come on and I'll chat about
all the intricacies and details we can dive as far into this
as you want but like for somebody who's been involved in so much
litigation of the past to try to like hamstring me and say now
you have to come on and have these conversations bro what the
am I going to say again you could my court filings are public
if you want to go read through the current court case your court
case has nothing to do with this your court case is like literally
irre you literally can't present the you've saved or say you
saved as evidence for the court case So there's no reason a lawyer
would have told you to save it. Just wouldn't have happened.
>> All the filings are public. The other side has put every
thing I've ever said online. They literally are linking directly
to Kiwi Farms in the court filings. You can go read them on the
docket. So the idea that you expect me to come out and and
what what is that supposed to mean >> here and say a bunch
of so I can pay my lawyers more money to respond to more emotions
is but I promise you as soon as my court case is you know done
I I not be your first interview. You want me to come on and go
through the details and run through all of that I would absolutely
love to do that with you. Um, I don't expect you to take uh to
take me up on that, but not to mention the fact that so I'm not
I'm not going to sit here and listen to him opineing on all of
the on on his theory. >> Yeah, I know. I know why you'd
skip that stuff. I'd skip that stuff, too. That seems pretty
up, guys. That's pretty spooky. All that stuff. >> He's
here. He says that I have um
like there's a whole bunch of like weird lies that came out of
the Willie Mack video. People were saying like I have 60 gigabyte
folders on my This is not true. It's like an obvious misreading
of a message that Willie Mack is showing on stream. Uh, >> it's
like a slight misreading. It's like in terms of Willie M like
being illiterate. That's like one of the least offensive things
he's done to be honest. Like Willie Mack is illiterate in all
kinds of offensive ways. He totally fabricates things. He is
the least reliable commentary YouTuber that exists. But like
pretty much that's like one of the more understandable mistakes
he's made. 60GB square. Let's go. We got it. We got it. 60 gig
60GB of CP. Guys, >> lies that he says something about
the fact that like I reached out to this person cuz I was like
trying to find young people on Twitter. That's not true. I typically
don't ever reach out to anybody. Almost everybody reaches out
to me. So, this is not even remotely true. Um I've never purchased
any from any of these people, anybody involved in any of this.
I typically just don't buy from people ever. I think it creates
a weird dynamic. So, that's completely not true. There's no evidence
of this anywhere. It's just random lies that are repeated. Uh
uh I could see that being true that he didn't buy from Rose and
that Rose reached out first. I could see both of those things
being true.
Wait, he didn't buy from Rose. I could say, unless there's some
evidence, I could see him not buying it. He obviously traded,
right? He obviously traded Rose. So, you can say he didn't buy
it, but I need to hear that he didn't possess it, which I don't
think he'll say cuz it's basically totally contradicted by the
DMs. Um I'm not gooning to any of this. I maybe for Ethan who's
used to just I guess off to or making jokes about going to, you
know, whatever material he's got on his computer. Uh, believe
it or not, I know it's hard to imagine because I'm not good at
crying on command. This entire court case and all of the leaks
of my explicit material has actually been incredibly disgusting
and invasive to my privacy. It's not actually fun for me to think
about it or to it or to think about anything related to it. >> I
just wonder why you do the same thing to other people. >> None
of it is. is actually pretty [__] disgusting to me.
But um yeah, I think he so he goes over the the Willie Mac video
and all this here. Uh
so again, not going to cite what Ethan's asking directly. He's
just going to explain it to his audience. Guys, you don't have
to watch this. I watched it so you don't have to. Okay? I'm going
to watch it and I'm going to tell you what they said and why
it was stupid.
>> Um up to 2559
>> in November, plenty of the waters, he hasn't done anything
wrong, right? Okay. Then this is when the mistakes begin in November
of 2024.
>> Oh,
her boyfriend reaches out to Steven and we have the DM because
her boyfriend >> Oh man, I really hope that he tries to
go, "Well, I didn't believe him."
>> You know what happened when when uh Solo told me that
she might be underage? I deleted the
image that I had. Okay. The the non-nude that I had, just a picture
of her face. I deleted that and I went, "Oh, I'm not touching
anything around that anymore. Oh, I'm done. Oh, no way. That's
weird. Okay. No, thank you. And by the way, I totally thought
he was lying. I totally thought he was like I thought for sure
he was lying to me. And I still was like, you know what? And
the off chance that said he's not lying. I'm not [__]
around. [__] that. [__] that. >> Wow.
I'm just I'm just random parts of this that he just tells lies
about. I like how every single time Ethan brings up the boyfriend
here, Ethan is acting like some person is reaching out to me.
It's like a cause of concern. This person was extorting and blackmailing
me to appear on my stream while they are leaking like dozens
of explicit videos of me. The way I think this is before they
leaked the explicit videos though, Destiny, I believe that the
way they were blackmailing you was saying that you have a lot
of really gross videos there that they could leak. They had not
leaked the videos yet. As far as I know, >> he frames all
of this is so insane. I don't even know if he knows the the situation
of anything that actually happened here. I have no idea. Um the
what other parts did I write here? Sometimes um
maybe you should have called the cops. I should have called the
cops cuz I thought this guy was lying and they used to run this
Twitter account. I didn't have any child born. I didn't Oh, Destiny.
I was like, bro, I listen I didn't know who these people were.
I had no information on them. I had like uh as much information
was on I guess like KF at the time or something. Took KF like
a day to find that stuff. >> There's this weird retroactive.
>> He He should have called the cops. Yes. Once uh once
it became clear that she might be a minor and he was holding
all that, he should have called the cops. >> Game that
Ethan likes to play saying that if somebody is selling like not
safe for word content on Twitter, that means that it's a huge
red flag and they're more likely to be um illegitimate. They're
not allowed to >> That's totally true. Yes. Somebody who
has none of those other age verified platforms and is selling
nudes on Twitter. Yes. Sell for one reason or another. This is
not true at all. Like I understand maybe you don't have any engagement
with this world. Plenty of people sell not safe for work material
on Twitter. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. The blackmail
wasn't serious if I recall correctly. Didn't he ask Destiny for
like a ridiculously low sum? No, he was like with Destiny. I
think he was always going to publish it to tell you the truth.
If I remember correctly, he was saying you should bring me on
stream cuz I don't like how people swept for you in the Lauren
Southern thing and if you don't like I'll publish these gross
videos of you. I think he was asking for stream time. I think
that was the way he was blackmailing. I don't even remember if
he asked for money. I I he might have. I don't see that or I
I don't remember that for sure. >> Twitter, it's literally
the only large social media platform that still allows you to
post not safe for work material. Um, Only Fans is basically worthless
if you don't have a pre-existing audience. This has nothing to
do with missing out on the marketplace and um
the marketplace on Only Fans. So, the discovery might be bad,
but the monetization and uh tools you can have on Only Fans are
way different. You can scale with Only Fans. The idea that she
wouldn't have an Only Fans is a red flag regardless of how little
marketing you could do on Only Fans. This is never going to be
a valid argument for not having both. It can only be a valid
argument for engaging on Twitter. Can't be a valid argument for
not having both.
Is this even true 3 years ago? I don't know. I think the girls
who use the hashtags like # NSFWTWT,
I think those are Tumblr girls to be honest because there's no
way to drive traffic to it. This is why people do um sell stuff
on Twitter. Uh the idea that you can go back and cherrypick like
some collection of facts that makes it so obvious that something
like there's not even like a way for me to disprove any of it.
There's like not even any solid accusations or claims made that
I can that I can
Okay, the there's a solid accusation or claim. The claim is you
were told she was under 18 in November of 2024. You retained
videos of her after that point and didn't inform authorities.
So much so that when your lawsuit happens in January 20th, you
copy all of those DMs and you retain them on another device.
All of that is backed up 100% by statements Destiny has made
or logs that exist. Okay, that is the allegation that you have
two months where you could have gotten rid of that material and
did not such that you copied it. Right? Or the other hypothesis
is he told Willie when Willie asked if you still had these videos,
he told Willie, "Yes, I've copied all of that because of my court
case."
So he just lied to Willie to make himself look like somebody
who is hoarding copies of child sex abuse materials. That's the
other option. Now neither one of those seems possible. The other
does not. Why? Why would you lie to Willie to make it look like
you have child sex abuse materials and send him a screenshot
of the title that shows a date that's clearly before this girl
turned 18? Did he ever say so? I think there's something that
comes here eventually egregious that is like not definitive and
not direct but is kind of hinting that direction, but I sincerely
doubt it because of the way he spoke to Willie Mack even that
I didn't even dive through given my uh ongoing case and everything.
So, if I would have known that Willie was going to be publishing
all my DMs publicly though, probably would have approached the
conversation with more care knowing that oh well, if all my DMs
are going to be read publicly, then I'm going to be I'm obvious.
So, where in those So, he doesn't analyze the DMs and he just
goes, "Guys, if I knew I was going to those that was going to
be published publicly, I would not have said what I said."
Okay.
Do you want to point out directly? No. No. No. Guys, beyond muddy
in the waters, I can't speak on it because of my legal case.
Am I speaking on it actively now? Yes. But it's to make things
less clear so I could, you know, have some plausible deniability,
not to answer questions.
>> Was it going to be a lot more precise with how I answer
these questions?
>> Claims to have hired a second set of lawyers to deal
with the criminal stuff. While he claimed that he had a law firm
from New York that was doing this. I don't know, man. >> But
the
what is this? >> Posted it. So here's her boyfriend.
>> Oh, he realized he hadn't skipped enough. Okay. So,
what is he skipping here? Or are we going to hit play? Cuz he's
about to go through the the actual narrative here, right? What
it should >> What is this? Brim posted it. So, here's her
boyfriend
at
>> right here. This is what he has to answer for. Okay.
This is May 30th, 2025. He says, "Guys, I just want to focus
on politics. I don't want to do drama anymore. They keep dragging
me back into into politics. They keep dragging me back into politics,
guys." It's like, "But Destiny, why did you dox this girl to
Kiwi Farms explicitly? Can't ability to investigate anything
is super pathetic. Why were you taunting Kiwi Farms while posting
where Rose went to college and multiple pictures of Rose's face
if you just wanted to do politics while taunting Kiwi Farms saying
Kiwi Farms can't find her?" Like, this will never not be the
funniest story I've ever seen I've ever witnessed on the internet
that this guy proved that he was in possession of with with no
reason to. Okay. He provided multiple different statements over
the course of days that proved that he was retaining child sex
abuse materials.
That's that's a level of self-owning that has never been seen
before. I defy you to find me an example from anywhere on the
internet that is even close.
I've never seen anything like that.
>> Yes, he just skipped along. And that's >> he just
skipped all of the stuff that you couldn't possibly deal with.
And his conduct, by the way, not stuff that he can go, "Well,
I can't explain that cuz of the court case, right?" His conduct,
his doxing of Rose, his trying to play footsie with Kiwi Farms
to dox Rose.
That's what he just skipped. He should have turned it in to the
authorities then. So, if you want to defend Destiny,
do that. But know that this guy knew there was a chance that
he had child on his on his hard drive. >> Like, what is
even this statement? This person knew there was a ch
>> for all this time. He kept it knowing that
that statement is
despite the fact that Destiny wouldn't trust Solo,
Solo did tell him that Rose was a minor for most of the stuff
she sent.
So the chance is there there's a chance she's a minor because
he told you she was a minor because you were told in November
2024, 2 months before any lawsuit was filed that she was a minor.
So, there was a chance she was a minor and you decided to retain
that that info, that media. What does that even mean? What does
that statement even mean? I don't even know what that statement
means. You think that has to do with you skipping a whole bunch
of the video that would have led up to that and made it make
sense or
and did nothing with it. Now, if you think that's cool and >> you
have no idea what I've done with anything, okay, I've retained
multiple law firms related to this case. Number one. Number two,
multiple law firms related to this case. Number one, you have
no idea what I did with anything.
Uh, it sure sounds like you kept copies. You said you kept copies.
And if he didn't keep copies, why wouldn't he just tell Willy
Mack, "No, obviously like with the videos and stuff, I sent that
on to the police." Why? Why didn't he just say, "Yeah, I sent
that on to the police." Why does he say, "Now, I sent it on to
the police." Why doesn't he Why does he just say, "You have no
idea what I've done." Why doesn't he just say, "I sent this to
the police back then. I sent it to the police." If that's true,
it all checks out and you like quell you quell the online narrative
and you're all fine. There's a very there's only one very specific
reason you would not make this clear right now. It's because
you did the bad thing and you want then the ambiguity people
thinking you might have done the bad thing is better than lying
or telling the truth.
So the ambiguity is the most beneficial situation. Saying you
have no idea what I did. Not saying what you did. You have no
idea what I did. Right? ambiguity is more beneficial than saying
than lying, which he could get in trouble for, I assume, right?
Or telling the truth and saying, "Uh, I didn't I didn't send
that stuff over." Or I mean, I guess somebody hypothetically
tell me what the downside of saying cuz there's only there's
only one downside I can kind of think of and it's possible,
but then I don't know why he's talking to Willie Mack about this
stuff. Okay, so there's one there's one downside, but I'm I'm
gonna leave that. I keep that in my head. If you guys can think
of another downside to him, if he's gone to the cops, if he went
to the cops when he was supposed to, why would he not just say,
"I went to the cops back when I first heard she was a minor and
gave them all of the all of the potential I had." I don't I don't
know what the downside to saying that is. I I would love to know
if anybody knows. If you give me a hypothetical here, I'd love
to know it. I do not possess any of this material on my computer.
That would be considered Why do you keep saying on your computer,
Stephen? Stephen, why do you keep qualifying? I don't possess
any of this material on my computer. Um, so anyway, like we can
all see what's happening here, right?
>> Do you think that's cool? >> Number one. Number
two, I do not possess any of this material on my computer that
would be considered or >> like if he is if he has followed
the authorities, like if he's followed the laws and he's been
above board the whole the whole way, he is doing the best job
he possibly can at convincing everybody that he was trying to
save Child, right? Why would you do that? He's not a total [__]
right? Or at least in the past, like in terms of actually understanding
logical premises that lead to conclusions, right? Like statements
of of fact that lead to conclusions. He's not a [__]
when it comes to that. He has to understand that he is painting
the picture that he has absolutely retained child in some way
and that he is not cooperating with the cops. He is painting
that picture himself through the things he says.
There's no way he's unaware of that. Like, I'm sorry.
Let's say hypothetically at the end of this he comes out and
says, "Oh, I did go to the cops right away
and like you guys are all I went to the cops right away and actually
here's the here's like a police report exonerating me." It's
like why didn't you just say that? Why didn't you Why was that
your statement? Hello?
Why did you dox Rose if that's the case? Did the cops ask you
to dox Rose? Could the cops not find Rose with the pictures of
her face and her
So you had to employ kiwi farms
like where how do we make any of the rest of this make sense?
I don't know >> CP or anything else you want to do call
it ever. And number three all of this is just stuff that you
are repeating verbatim that you heard on kiwi farms. And four
it's just kiwi farms. This is all kiwi farms. Guys this is just
kiwi farms. Okay. I thought you knew better than to snark like
this. Ethan. This is just kiwi farms. It's all kiwi farms. Kiwi
Farms. Kiwi Farms.
Destiny, aren't you the one who helped Kiwi Farms find her? Didn't
you give all of the private PII that only you had? Didn't you
give that to Kiwi Farms so they could find her? Sounds like you
think Kiwi Farms is pretty reliable for finding people. He literally
said, "Don't forget guys, I'm the one who gave all the information
away to find her so that Kiwi Farms could go look her up." Okay?
Why Why would we not believe Kiwi Farms when you trusted them
to find her? Right?
He said that. He said, "Don't forget guys that I'm the one who
gave the info to Kiwi Farms that let them find her ostensibly
to make the point that there was no way he thought she was below
18, right? That's why he said that." But he still relied on them
to find her apparently.
And and then he's supposed to expect us to go, "Oh, anything
from Kiwi Farms, we don't trust that." Well, Destiny trusts them
completely. Or there's not even a way that I could prove this.
Like, I don't even know what I'm supposed to do. Like, do do
you want to come through and go through my entire computer, my
entire folder structure, my entire like I don't even know what
I could possibly even say other than no and then you going, well,
what about this? Well, no. Like, it's such a stupid like unwinable
argument. Um, like if it was again, >> we've had bingos
already. We've had bingos through my entire computer, my entire
folder structure, my entire like I don't even know what I could
possibly even say other than no and then you going, "Well, what
about this?" Well, no. like honor before honor before December
or sorry November like 24th 2024 I deleted all videos pertaining
to Rose all possible I deleted all of those videos and I informed
the police that's all you have to say you stretch it out to December
25th December 26th like or sorry November 25th November 26th
right you could say all that I removed all possession all copies
of this uh surrendered them to police I retained no copies of
any of this in any form under no ownership of my own.
You just you just make that statement wholesale, right? If you
want to make that statement wholesale, I think that then then
you have a statement on the record. You're saying I'm making
that statement on the record,
but you're not making that statement. You're not saying anything.
Like it's such a stupid like unwinable argument. Um like if it
was again, hey, listen, people want to contact authorities. I'm
all for that. Again, I even said if Willie Mack wants to call
authorities uh because he thinks it's good use for the FBI time,
then go for it. That's fine. I just don't know why the he would
make public video. >> Does he know? Did Willie Mack call
the FBI? Is that who Willie Mack called? I have no idea who Willie
Mack called >> about all this that I >> Will Mack
wants to call the FBI. >> If it was again, hey, listen,
people want to contact authorities, I'm all for that. Again,
I even said if Willie Mack wants to call authorities uh because
he thinks it's good use for the FBI time, then go for it. despite
what Willie Mie Mack making the mistake on the um what is it
on saying that he has it on his computer now and the mistake
on how much how many gigabytes desk he was in uh possession of
this is like the best use of the FBI's time. This is every single
police officer dreams of like stopping child abuse. That's like
they are here to defend the kids. Okay, they're that lady from
the Simpsons who goes, "Oh, what somebody think of the children?"
That's every cop ever. Listen to Connor speak and any other time
he's not been around this specific topic with regards to Destiny
and he's all about protecting kids, right? The FBI loves
loves jailing child predators and people who have child that
they love that [__] Him calling out the FBI is probably
not a good time. I'm just bro he's he's sitting here like like
it's a good idea for him to say, "Well, are you sure that this
is a good use of the FBI's time given those DMs?" Yes.
It's like the best use of the FBI's time. And if it's not a good
use of the FBI's time, I am curious why you made it so clear
that you have child in your possession in those DMs. Why would
you do that? That seems like a crazy thing to do. Well, that's
fine. I just don't know why the you would make public videos
about all of this that I for a number of reasons is impossible
for me to respond to if for no other reason because I'm getting
swatted and FBI called me constantly. three because I have an
active civil case going that is directly related to some of these
conversations which and again um yeah it's just such an unbelievably
crazy bind to stick me in and then pretend that he's making you
know some type of strong argument that I'm some kind of online
predator based on Ryan Beard's videos with random >> in
the context of everything else of him
>> just all you have to do is go read go watch you just
skip the entire section laying this out and it's like I can't
believe he tried to do this with only the Ryan Beard can you
believe he only tried to do this with like Ryan Beard's >> and
trying to normalize
activity with minors. Like at what point has this ever been the
case? Has there ever ever been a clip of me on stream ever saying,
"I think you should be able to [__] 15y olds. I think
you should be able to [__] 12 year olds. I think
you should be able to [__] 17 year olds." Like that's
what we got from the six or seven clips earlier. Really?
He has he's been doing this over the span of his entire career.
If you think that is fine and holding on to potential child is
fine, then go ahead and defend Destiny. But just know that is
what you're defending. Those are the facts, Jack. >> I
reported this to the police and recorded my interactions and
calls with the detective. >> [__] Willy Mad
Cry compromising the bikini pics of 15-year-old. So listen, the
guy's a creep. He's a If I were a DJer,
well, I can't really hypothesize how a DJer would think anymore
because they obviously are missing significant chunks of their
white and gray matter. But
hypothetically,
you're somebody who cared about intellectual honesty, you might
wonder why Destiny skipped over very specific sections of this
video and why he refused to address any of the arguments made
therein. You might wonder these things. Okay, if you had any
curiosity, any intellectual curiosity at
you might think about it. Okay,
I can't believe I sat here. I watched the whole Ethan video and
basically where Destiny cuts out, I'm like, "Oh, yes. This is
the section now. He's he's saying these things. These are the
things I've been saying. I want to see how Destiny responds to
this." He cuts both sides of it, right?
And just goes to the end and goes, "This is what they were saying
there, guys." Like, it's mindboggling.
It's
>> Degenerate. There's no other way. Like if you listen
if you want to think I'm a creeper degenerate then fine then
[__] go for it. But my brother in Christ, okay, we
are two P's in a degenerate pod and I think you're lower on the
rung there than I am. If that's seriously the thing you want
to go like the most embarrassing part for me putting all this
video together was I think I was I might have actually been outedged
by this guy. Okay, I thought I was the edge lord and
this guy is
out he's out edgeing me on which was supposed to be my domain
according to this guy. But wait to cut it. If you if you like
Destiny, if you think he's smart and cool and funny and awesome,
good. Keep watching him. But know that you are supporting someone
who has attracted 15-year-olds who shared compromising bikini
pics a 15-year-old sent to him with compromising. These are pictures
posted publicly on social media people at the beach again. Like,
>> what were your comments on them again? Um, hold on.
Do I have his comments on them? Maybe I have. Oh, I don't have
the Imager album here anymore. Was it like, it's so hard to resist.
These people are total jailbait. It's so hard to say no. Listen,
you thought because of those pictures. I just want I just go
off of your opinion. Okay. I can't see the pictures. Your opinion,
Destiny, was it's so hard to say no to some of these girls.
Okay, that was your that was your position. What the? He's acting
like I'm getting like nudes from kids, which maybe he I don't
know. Maybe. >> He has held on knowing there's a chance
of child for 6 months and never reported it to the authorities.
You >> have no idea what's on my computer. You have no
idea what I've reported to authorities. You have no idea about
literally any of this. You can just easily clear that up. There's
no reason why a civil case would block you from saying you took
the Rose videos to the police as soon as you could. There's just
no there's no conflict there at all. There's no possible conflict.
He could just say that right now and solve a ton of his problems
or at least put them off until people realize he's possibly lying.
But if he's not lying, then he he'd just be fine. Where's the
downside? again. You're just reading down snark threads or kiwi
farms >> that he assaulted a woman on camera.
>> What do you want me to do you want me to go back in
time and kill myself? Like what the [__] >> You
want to come at me and say, "Oh, you got all this thing wrong.
You're gas litter and you're lying all this shit." Bro, uncontroversial
facts. >> True. I do agree with that. Okay. And I am glad.
I guess that we got to have this back and forth. As fun as this
is, >> you are up to defend this guy. And like I guess
I don't know if you're being gaslit or misled, but like >> so
many people saying yeses in the chat right now. Jesus. >> Watching
the video that Abba made with all of this context out here and
he he's accusing me of not >> absolutely terrible comments
you guys >> of him confessing to knowingly having >> absolutely
terrible comments. I totally >> absolutely not what I quote
unquote confessed to
potential child on his hard >> That is absolutely not what
I quote unquote confessed to. And again, I didn't know that these
obviously I wouldn't be making jokes,
>> dude. What? Okay. Like we we can't go around this. Okay.
He says I retained copies of these things. He doesn't say on
my computer, right? And now when he says I don't possess any
copies of these, he says on my computer, right? It seems pretty
obvious that all this works if he's just got all of these videos
on a hard drive that's not connected to his computer currently.
That might not be in his possession, even in his building right
now, but is his,
right? like and he has to know that that's how it sounds and
that's how everybody receives it. Why is he making us all think
that he's got child if he doesn't and [__] and putting
l W faces around this? If I knew that Will Mack was going to
decide to publish all of our conversations on this, right? It's
so insane that a private conversation I'm having with a guy relating
to all of this is then published and it's like okay well now
you need to line by line defend everything Jesus what the was
in a public statement. Not to say that like I'm revealing some,
you know, explicit whatever detail, but more so that just like
obviously if I'm going to know that this is going to be publicly
released, I'm going to be phrasing these things a lot more carefully.
I'm going to be a lot more precise in my statements here. But
he's acting like this was some type of interrogation to be released
and that I like failed the interrogation. But
you literally say if you're sending me this, I'm guessing you
still have that video. The video that would make her You're saying
I you're you're literally saying you're talking about the video
here. You you sent a screenshot of it. says, "If you were sending
me this, I'm guessing you still have that video." Depends on
why you're asking. But yes,
but yes.
What could the but yes be referring to? There's no way. I I didn't
think it was possible, but he's going to gaslight his audience
on a clear admission of guilt again.
Again, somehow. Sorry, not to hit that high note, but he's somehow
going to actually gaslight his audience into believing that his
outright confession of guilt is made up again. So, there was
the whole thing with Trader Aid where he says, "Yeah, uh, she
says, "Oh, you you didn't even um leak it. You sent it non-consensually."
He goes, "Yeah, and I know I've violated her privacy in the most
egregious of ways." And he goes, "I didn't mean I I did something
wrong. I just meant like I felt bad cuz a leak came out, you
know."
And this time he's not even going to actually address. Apparently,
he skipped over the DMs before. Maybe he'll address it here at
the end. Apparently, he's not even going to address what this
one means.
You need the Myin sound bite. Hold on. I might have it here.
There you go again.
He did it again.
We need some mugs to smash. Okay, we need mugs to smash again.
But again, despite all of that, listen, if you want to call the
FBI, you want to report or whatever, then hey, you know, Willie
did it, that's fine. I have no problem with that. I just don't
know why you would make public videos on expecting me to be able
to publicly respond to prove that I don't have stuff on my computer.
I don't even know what that looks like. Never commented on that.
You only commented on things that I got wrong. Right. Again,
very easy statement. When I was informed that Rose may have been
underage, I took the necessary steps to follow the law, contacted
police, and remove and had removed from my custody all copies
of this occurred in November 2024. Done and dusted.
Done
and dusted. That's all you got to do. And that's a statement
that doesn't actually affect anything. Okay? It doesn't actually
affect anything. It's all good if we just follow that along.
He doesn't want to do it for >> ignore the whole context.
You're sweeping the whole context. >> What looks to me
to be a consistent
long-term, highly motivated, premeditated child predator. That's
what he looks like to me. >> Consistent, long-term, highly
motivated child predator. Okay. There's only >> Yeah, I
think uh I think Ethan just goes way too hard. I don't know why
he's going to stretch those allegations so hard. Ethan's kind
of It is what it is. It is what it is.
one consistent long-term child predator that I'm aware of in
this circle.
I didn't want to bring this up, but >> you can see my buttons
are open. >> Oh my goodness. I was 16 years old here. >> Wow,
look at you guys. Oh my god. 21 and I'm down. >> That if
that happened today, bro, you >> Oh, I
What was Destiny in the uh in the faith? Hold on. Hold on.
21 and 16. That's horrible. That's horrible. Wait, what? Where
did you want to [__] that 15-year-old? How old were
you at the time? You were you were 23. You say you were 20. Or
was he 21? Maybe he's 21, but it's still slightly bigger. I guess
Ethan's Ethan Klein's dad did actually this 16-year-old pretty
bad. >> I know. >> I know.
>> Now, to be fair, I don't know. Maybe they weren't out.
>> he's watched the clip. He postes the clip. He knows
they're he knows that the dad tries to go, "We didn't until we're
married." Or e Ethan might say that. And the mom is like, "Why
are you lying?" "Yeah, of course we [__] as soon
as we Dude." His mom's like, "Actually funny." His mom's like,
"Yeah, of course we when when you were 21 and I was 16." >> Dude,
that's rough. >> But you know what? I was more mature than
he was. >> Well, I believe that. I actually do believe
that. >> But look at her. I mean, she
just came off the cover of >> Dude, 21.
Were you guys Were you guys having a
>> none of your business?
What? >> That's my goal.
>> Did you guys you know the deal? >> She was 18.
in love. >> Destiny thought Dioro was cool. Weman
now deleted tweet.
Hold on. Respond substantively to everything. Oreo counters by
showing a clip of me with Dan in a pregame war zone lobby like
I'm making a serious claim. Thanks for lining up them up for
me. All you do is make me look better in the long run, fatty.
And it's a cream clip. Uh, that's tough. That's tough. That's
a tough one. Unfortunate.
Queen needs to diet. I've heard. Okay. I've heard some people
have started call taking to calling Quman the hungry hungry Hebrew.
Is this true? Is this the word word on the street is he's becoming
known as the hungry hungry Hebrew. That's rough. Okay. I I don't
know. I'm just I'm saying this is what I've heard. I don't know
if this is true. All right. Well, let's continue with this. I
think he's basically done though. >> That's so crazy. Yeah,
you could not do that today. I mean, that would be just like,
wo there, buddy. >> So, we're in San Francisco. Terrible.
>> Maybe he thinks his dad is a too, I guess, and that's
why he's justifying calling me a Maybe he's willing to take that
leap. But, >> I don't know. My closing thing on this is
I don't think Ethan is a In fact, I'm going to be honest. I was
going through probably like 70% of these videos. I thought it
was I thought they were funny because I appreciate old internet
edgy humor. Okay. I didn't think a lot of these things were funny.
I don't think Ethan is a I don't think he's intentionally uh
um predatoring. There's a verb there that I'm like praying on
children or trying to normalize children to his audience. Although
I will admit that that Boston bober one, that 17-year-old one
really tested the boundaries there that was really pushing pushing
boundaries on that one. But um the the the annoying thing is
I don't think he's I don't even think he thinks I'm a I don't
think he can possibly think that. Um, like I have had, not to
get into the weird whatever territory, but I've hooked up with
a lot of people over the past 15 years. They say there's like
a pattern of children or whatever. It's just absolutely not true.
Some of my biggest egirl dramas have been with women that Oh,
Anavore. Anavore was my age, therefore I have no problems here,
guys. How could Rose be a minor if Anavar is of age?
Guys, how could be honest, how could Rose be a minor if Anavar
was of age? That doesn't even make sense. Just think about that
in your head for two seconds. Okay, that's impossible. Annavar
is a 30-year-old woman. How could Rose be 17?
Wow. Thank I didn't I never thought about it that way, Destiny.
I never once thought about it that way. That's That's really
smart, actually. Uh I just I'm full on, you know, I'm I'm getting
on the train of making massive accusations with no proof. Okay,
I replied to that or quote tweeted that Queen tweet and just
said like, "Who told you to tweet this?" He didn't even listen
to the tweet. If you listen to the tweet, you know that the British
guy is not Nicholas Dioro, right? Maybe he doesn't know who Nicholas
Dioro is that well, but you know the British guy is not Nicholas
Dioro. He didn't even listen to the tweet. Somebody just told
him to tweet it and he did because he's a [__] How
embarrassing. Juice box. I got juice boxes. Nice. Let me pin
that in the chat. Guys, interact with the tweets. Like the tweets.
>> There it is.
All right, we continue on with this video. We're getting close.
We're almost [__] This girl was like two years younger
than me. Okay. The idea that there's like some huge pattern established
of young women of me praying on people is absolute
and plenty of people have tried to say this over and over again
every single time it falls apart because it's always the same
three or four stupid clips that come out over and over again.
Um, I look forward to making the same type of video, I guess,
like two or three or four years from now when somebody else decides
to dig it all up again and be like, "Oh, what about this story?"
Like, by that point, like my my clips on by that point, hopefully
Desty's, you know, 10 to 15 years for child possession. Hopefully,
that's the ideal sense. Okay, the ideal situation.
That'll be what it is. On talking about minors will be old enough
for me to the clips themselves and for it to not be. though.
Um I don't know if Ethan feels like he has to disavow me because
he wants to lose like the Destiny puppet allegations. Uh there
are easier ways for him to do that if he wants to drop the Destiny
puppet allegations. Like we guys, there's no way that these content
creators could all just think that I am a predator of some kind,
right? There's that's obviously not true. There's no way they
could all just dislike me and think I'm a creepy weirdo who probably
tries to teenagers, right? There's no way. There's no way, guys.
It has to be something else. It has to be something else. No,
Destiny. They just all think you're a creepy weirdo now.
You've proven that out through various through multiple
crime allegations at this point. I guess allegations, crime scandals,
right? There's just been like stuff keeps coming and it is not
the same. By the way, the idea that Rose was 17 was something
he totally played off as a Kiwi Farms conspiracy for months and
months and months. And now he helped Kiwi Farms prove it against
himself. And now he's like, "Oh, well, this is the same thing
they've been saying forever." Same same theory, but proven this
time. Okay. I don't know if you realize this, but I I believe
is it Capernacus
or Galileo who's the first person who suggested that the sun
was the center of the universe and they got burned for it. Okay,
you can have a theory and if you're correct, it doesn't matter
if you've got no proof. You need some proof. Okay? And even then,
sometimes people might not be ready for it. All right? Now, we
know for a fact Rose is 17. It's way different. It's way different.
We could argue about something. Um, we he could call me a Gusano.
He could make fun of my laning in League. Uh, you know, there's
lots of things that can trigger the [__] out of me.
Like I don't know why he's so weak willed and so spineless that
he gives into his crew immediately that he gives into his baser
instincts immediately and in a desperate attempt to throw off
the Destiny allegations he decides to just start going in on
me on like probably one of the worst topics that he could go
in on me for. I don't know why the he would do this. Uh like
bro like if there's some secret ring the only reason you know
I'm there is cuz you're in the meetings. Like holy [__]
these videos are insane for him to make these types of accusations
on me. So come on bro.
I don't know. Like, now the annoying thing is I know that since
I've responded to this, I'm sure he has to do a response about
me. I don't know if it's just going to literally be us um going
back and forth through whoever has the deeper Snark threads,
whoever has the deeper Kiwi Farms threads. Um, and to and we're
just going to rehash that for the next like two weeks or he's
just got like so many words quoted up at this point. Destiny
does that like trigger the victim the victimhood response from
his audience. They're like, "Oh, I forgot you were persecuted.
You were prosecuted. You were maligned for that." Gusano. Gusano.
Gusano. Oh, you were they were racist to you. They were racist
to you. Right. Two months or year or whatever until he gets bored.
I don't know how long it takes Ethan to tucker himself out.
Um, but yeah, I will say thumbs up to the anti-fan communities
out cuz I know that the snarkers and the kiwi farmers love this
type of fighting. Uh, congratulations Ethan. I know they love
it. They're loving the back and forth right now. You're giving
the anti-fan communities. It's all Ethan's fault. It's not Destiny's
fault for actually with a girl who is clearly borderline on.
She's clearly on the line of leg legality no matter what. Right?
It's not Destiny's fault at all. Nothing here could possibly
be Destiny's fault, guys. It's all not Destiny's fault. All right.
It's wise for Destiny to bring up that Ethan must be trying to
dodge the Destiny allegations.
Uh, no. Yeah, no. Stop when he didn't get that ID. Oh, frugals.
But have you seen Tom Fury's suspicions about this?
Tom believes there might have been an ID exchanged somehow. If
he just makes up DMs, he could totally hypothesize an ID that
was given, which is kind of cool. Kind of cool, kind of weird
to be honest. I'm looking for What am I looking for? I'm looking
for some logs that were sent to me earlier today of just like
some of the DG code. I'm looking for it. Trying to find it. Sorry,
I'm going through my DMs and there are some funny things here.
Yo, guys responding with 120K live viewers. Did my guy really
skip over our entire DMs? Cuz you are. Yes. This is what you
get for platforming Odishar's allegations, too, Willy. You get
You're about to be ratioed by a total [__] You're
about to be ratioed by somebody who sober is probably about your
IQ, but is high all of the time. How you like them apples, bro?
How you like them apples? Everybody getting their comeuppants
today. You love to see it. You love to see it. Okay. I had some
other things in the docket for today as well, so we'll get on
to those. >> Possible. the absolute best show that they
could possibly hope for. And you know, I guess at least I'm making
some money out of it. You're making some money out of it. I guess
at the end of the day, we don't give a about anything besides
that, right? If that's what this is all about, then good job.
But
yeah, based base memes, >> super based. Let me join up
in the Discord. See if uh anyone's coming on tonight. See what's
going on. >> Um okay, I'm done with all this today for
now. And I'm sure AB Stariller is already working on his next
research >> Shot at AB. Shot at AB. Shot at AB. Right at
the end. Right under the wire,
Shot at AB. Right under the wire. You love to see it.
There's just fit defamation. He knowingly lied and called you
anyway despite saying things. No, cuz it's defamation against
public figures. It's just, trust me, it's really, really, really
hard to pursue those. And it's like, bro, the litigation [__]
I'm in right now is already insanely tiresome. Like the idea
of like taking up more of that is not it's not anything that
I would
Okay. Thank you for the short.
>> That's a bingo.
Damn. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. What are we looking for here?
We're looking
There's a couple things.
So, I think we're going to go and look at the um the astroturfing
going on between these communities. I think that would be very
funny. I'm going to look for more examples of it. But um there
was this this thread here.
News flash. Ethan isn't his father. Trigger discussion of CSA.
I'm a CSA survivor. My biological father went to prison for CSA.
He was not my abuser. Dude, that's up, isn't it? Is that Is that
enough up for that kid?
He's He's a CSA survivor whose father didn't go to prison, but
was not attractive enough to his father to be abused by his father.
Do you think that sticks with this guy? that sticks with him
like to this day. Hey, I'm not joking about the kids being attractive
to me. I'm joking about them this this kid being attractive to
his child father. Okay,
I I I don't find kids attractive at all. That gross.
Maybe it was a swapping situation. Oh, that's so much worse than
my comment. Jesus Christ. Oh, that's terrible.
As someone who's essayed as a child under 10 years old, I really
don't give a [__] that Ethan calls Dest. I don't
care if it's a misnomer. No matter
what name you call want to call him, the bottom line is that
Destiny is a predator and his victims are young girls. Stop censoring
his feelings about being labeled as something over the voices
of his >> Ben Ruben donated $3. There are still people
waving the CSA flag. >> What? I don't even know what that
means, but thank you. Today I see fans lurking here with hate
and hostility. middle finger. Now, hold on. Which one of these
comes first? They can't Are they both from the same person? They're
not. They're mirror threads. So, this is the first one that went
up in DG.
I kind of I kind of wondered why they were both up. I'm a CSA
survivor. My biolog biological father went to prison for CSA,
who's not my abuser. Seeing Ethan's fans used to edgy humor mistakes
he's owned up to is some sort of condemnation is beyond gross.
When Ethan's own father raped Ethan's mother at 16, and Ethan
has nothing to say about that. As someone who essayed as a child
under 10 years old, I really don't give a [__] that
Destiny calls Ethan's dad a care if it's a misnomer. No matter
what name you want to call him, the bottom line is that Ethan's
father is a predator and his victim was 16 years old that he
raped. Stop centering his feelings about being labeled something
over the voices of his victims. To Ethan's fans lurking here
with hate and hostility, middle finger. Wait, stop centering
his feelings about being labeled something over the voices of
his victims. Wait, his victim is like still married to him. What?
I think this one must have been first, but Oh, no. No, no, no.
The the H3 one was first. So,
wow. These these communities are going to hate each other. It's
going to be awesome. Was obviously first. Well, this seemed too,
but yes, it is first.
So, stop centering Desty's feelings about being labeled something
over the voices of his victims. I don't know. In terms of the
kids, I'm not sure we have victims there. Predator probably okay.
Maybe okay. The H3 subreddit is so gone. I was looking for Yeah.
funny meme post like this. Kathy, thank you. Kathy knows. Kathy
knows. We're looking for the cope everywhere we can get it. Is
the H3 subreddit. Let's go. As a big H3 fan, I got to say Destiny
had a pretty good response.
Holy. How hard is it to do proper research before making such
damning claims? So much context is lacking from the clips Ethan
used. It literally self-sabotage. Also, those old Ethan clips.
Jesus Christ. We get a lot of SNH3 fan. Okay.
I
h very funny stuff. Holy [__] I turned on the stream
and the first thing that's on is a clip of Ethan talking about
juvenile and how he wants to throat underage girl LMFAO. These
are from the thread that got deleted.
Dude, this is uh there's so many jokes. There's so many jokes
that I can't get to. I feel like if you're on some online, some
anonymous online forum and somebody goes as like a German, as
a Canadian, as an American, as somebody who does that, you could
like almost certainly just say they're not that thing like every
single time.
It's super funny. Destiny is responding to Ethan's video on stream
right now.
Wish I could have a time machine and make Ethan not do leftovers.
We'd be in a much better timeline. Very different from Hassan's
method.
Turns out a clip taken out of context by Ethan was one where
Destiny was calling out a white nationalist directly on stream
for abducting an it Oh no. This is this is total No, it's not.
No, it's not. Dude, Destiny just totally lied. Destiny was making
the ex Oh, wait.
Sorry. There's two things going on there. There's Ethan completely
like reversing the clip's meaning, which was stupid. But Destiny
was saying that like, oh, I'm talking about like I'm talking
about calling out somebody who abducted a mentally girl. And
then you listen to the clip and it's like clearly him saying
that if you as a 30-year-old man are attracted to somebody who's
19 or 15, you basically have the same pathology. You're a weirdo.
Yeah. Um and then he said it was mostly it had to do with like
the old thing. I mean Jeff is a white supremacist, right? Yeah.
The issue is Ethan just thought it was Dest saying like 15year-olds
are basically 19 so I want to [__] them anyway. That's
wrong.
That's Ethan being a total but unlucky. Fact that Ethan is thinking
Tiny is doing a Hassan is so funny. You new H3 fans that joined
in the Trisha arc are in for a treat. I recommend everyone to
be fair and watch this Ethan video was insanely unfair and this
time unironically devoided of any context. Trying not to do the
Hassan meme. You can do this this type of stuff. Uh-huh.
Dude, the context that was missing is not the context that was
actually the context that Deste was saying was missing is not
applicable to like his his overall, but it is what it is. Can't
wait for Britney Simon's opinion. She hates everyone here. We
all hate everyone here. It's all It's all W's. It's all awesome.